Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Oh, ich hab's nicht gedacht.
Chat ist verdeckt.
Der Pepo ist zu weit heute.
Und probier mal KDE aus.
Ihr wisst, ich bin überhaupt kein Linux-Desktop-Fanboy von allem anderen außer i3.
Und Wayland kommt mir gerade noch nicht in die Tüte, weil es nicht gescheit funktioniert bei mir hier.
Gerade in der VM.
Doch, doch. Ich hab aber das schon ewig her.
ich meine ich habe alles schon mal irgendwann irgendwie mir angeguckt unter linux so was des
tops angeht aber kde boah weiß nicht ob wir überhaupt jemals im stream schon kde hatten
also mein letzte installation mit kde das ist bestimmt schon 15 jahre her
da hatten die noch dieses komische k mit den zahnrädern als logo das haben die ja auch
mittlerweile nicht mehr ich habe jetzt noch vier plätzchen die muss ich jetzt essen
was ist denn die beste distribution um kde auszuprobieren
cash ios oder sowas in der richtung so voll angesagt gerade müssen wir mal gucken wir
Wir können tatsächlich mal CacheOS.
Wir können tatsächlich mal...
Ne, wir installieren mal CacheOS.
Habe ich noch nie installiert.
Das Ding ist, ich installiere es in der VM, weil ich gerade keinen Bock habe hier...
Bare Metal.
Ich habe hier eine Kiste stehen.
So ein Minisforum.
Mini-PC.
Irgendwo. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo er hin ist.
Er stand immer hier.
Ach, da hinten in der Kiste ist er.
Aber dann müsste ich extra Tastatur anschließen, Capture Card anschließen.
Das ist immer so eklig.
Und zum einfach ausprobieren, wenn man jetzt nicht die krass Performance braucht, reicht das ja auch.
Ist CacheOS nicht auch KDE?
Doch, oder?
Doch, doch.
Doch, doch, gibt's auch hier.
Es hat geschneit, ja.
Wenn ihr jetzt mein letztes Plätzchen gefordert habt,
zeige ich euch was richtig Nices,
was ich entdeckt habe,
auf Shithub.
Ich habe ein bisschen rumgebastelt.
Das ist exzellent.
So.
Schätzchen gefressen.
So muss es sein.
Also wie gesagt, es hat geschneit.
Es schneit gerade nicht.
Es hat geschneit.
Gestern war alles ziemlich weiß.
aber dann war es deutlich über 0 Grad, da ist es meistens schon geschmolzen.
Heute ist es eigentlich nur noch ziemlich glatt an einigen Stellen, aber Schnee ist der größte Teil weg.
Direkt von KDE, ne, wir installieren CacheOS.
Wir können das schon mal runterladen, wo gibt es denn das hier?
CacheOS Download.
Das hier.
Select your preferred edition
Ach hier kann man dann auswählen oder wie
Ähm
Und wo wählt man das jetzt aus
Achso
Ach das kann man dann bei der Installation wahrscheinlich auswählen
Na gut
Dann laden wir das mal runter
Dann zeige ich euch gleich noch was anderes
Oder ich warte noch bis der Stream richtig angelaufen ist
desktop edition direkt download
herrscher wie gesagt wir mal keine spiele test oder sowas da drauf dafür
eignet sich das jetzt nicht in der vm da müssen wir das war wirklich auf der
diese minis forum pc da ist auch amd hardware drin was viel besser
funktioniert und erledigungs ps fox für den sub das ist ja
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob das taugt.
Soll der super vorkonfiguriert sein?
Wir haben auch C++ Zeug auf.
MonkaS, Alter.
Nix wie weg.
Ganz schnell.
Wir machen mal kurz Arch Linux.
Package Updates, wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind.
Okay.
Was ist David?
Warum habe ich das überhaupt installiert?
Was ist das?
AV1 Cross-Plattform.
Okay, Video Decoder.
Na dann.
updaten wir das mal ich will einfach mal gucken ob mir kde gefällt also es hat es
hat tatsächlich ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr hintergrund als ich will
es einfach nur ausprobieren das ding ist die tage von x11 scheinen ja so langsam
aber sicher gezählt dass ich meine das wird kein von heute auf morgen geht es
nicht mehr aber ich gehe davon aus dass in den nächsten jahren immer mehr
software ihre x11 unterstützung rausschmeißen wird und irgendwann auch
die distribution anfangen das nicht mehr richtig einzubinden uns probleme gibt
und so was ich das ist halt ein ziemlicher kack zustand weil man hat
seine riesen hat immer noch seine probleme vieles geht hat und erweilert
gar nicht richtig in der vm funktioniert auch nicht richtig und deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht nutzen wir mal wailand in kombination mit kd ich glaube
mittlerweile kannst ja kd auch gar nicht mehr mit xl doch ich glaube ich x11
gibt es noch, aber nur zusätzlich irgendwie sowas
benutzen und
vielleicht taugt das ja,
sodass man es in Zukunft verwenden könnte,
sollte mein X-Setup
nicht mehr funktionieren.
Ja, damit wird alles gut,
wenn die Sachen rewritten in ZIG oder
Rust wären.
Jaja, ich weiß,
das ist wohl eines der besseren
Implementierung,
das funktioniert wohl angeblich in der vm auch ganz gut weil alles was ich bisher mit
wale in der vm ausprobiert habe war schrott aber kde mit walein habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert
ich habe sway ausprobiert und hyperland ausprobiert ich wollte mal demnächst mango
oder wie das heißt ausprobieren vielleicht tut das besser und da habe ich da genau das habe ich
auch schon gelesen, das hat wohl ganz gut funktioniert.
Deswegen wollte ich es mal ausprobieren.
69 Zuschauer haben wir wieder.
69 war ja früher auch schon
nicht lustig, aber immerhin ist es lustiger als
67.
67 ist einfach
nur richtig dumm.
Aber ich bin wahrscheinlich einfach nicht
Generation Alpha
genug dafür.
so haben jetzt alles geupdatet ja das session has expired oh das ist schlecht da muss ich
bei gelegenheit hier nochmal einloggen aber so dass ihr nicht zugucken können ich zeige
euch jetzt mal was wichtig ich lege doch hier im stream wenn man hier so unter repos guckt ich
lege doch so viele Projekte an, wo wir hier basteln.
Ja, dann basteln wir zwei, drei Tage dran
und dann machen wir das nächste.
Und nachdem ich
jetzt hauptsächlich Dev-Container
verwende,
um da drin zu entwickeln, ist das
alles vom Setup her immer ein bisschen
aufwendiger, als einfach nur zu sagen
.NET New oder
Cargo New oder irgendwie sowas.
Deswegen habe ich mal geguckt,
ob es
Projekt-Templating
Projekte gibt. Und da habe ich eins gefunden, das ist sogar
super beliebt auf GitHub.
Kennt das jemand von euch vielleicht?
Das habe ich gefunden.
Das habe ich mir heute mal im Laufe des Tages ein bisschen
angeguckt. Damit kann man
aus Templates
fertige
Projekt-Directories erzeugen. Ich zeige euch das
mal. Ich habe hier einen Ordner mit Templates
drin. Die habe ich heute angelegt.
Hier, Repos.
Templates.
Da ist ein Template drin für Rust und für Go.
Jetzt kann man einfach sagen, ich muss Cookie Cutter installieren.
Das ist auch als Standardpaket drin.
Verwendet das jemand von euch?
Also vielleicht hat das ja jemand schon länger im Einsatz.
Das ist relativ bekannt.
24.500 Sterne auf GitHub.
Ist also kein 5 Sterne, 1 Mann Projekt.
also und wenn ich jetzt sagen will okay leute heute machen wir also ist nur exemplarisch ja
wir machen heute keine go anwendung aber oder keine rast anwendung wenn ich jetzt sagen würde
ihr leute heute bauen wir eine rast web anwendung zum beispiel ja da kann ich jetzt einfach sagen
cookie cutter templates rust projekt name rust example champ und schon habe ich hier
rust example champ ein fertiges rust projekt directory wie man hier sieht mit passenden
Bild und Run Scripts, passender
Readme,
naja, passender Readme ist schön und gut,
passendem
Docker-File
und alles, was man dafür so braucht.
Jetzt kann ich einfach sagen,
ähm,
connecte mich auf
meine Entwicklungs...
Wie sieht so ein Template? Zeige ich gleich.
Connecte mich auf meine
Container, mach eine IDE auf.
Welche IDE willst du verwenden?
es ist Rust, also
Rust Rover verwenden, so und dann
muss der einmal halt den Container bilden
für die, für dieses
Projekt und dann einmal die
IDE Sachen rüber kopieren, das dauert so
1-2, naja Minute
vielleicht 1-2 Minuten
und dann ist das fix und fertig
und dann ist das, ist man quasi
ready to go, ich hab auch schon
Template Sachen eingefügt
in dem Fall für Rust, wo standardmäßig
so ein paar Pakete drin sind, die ich immer
brauche und
so mein Logger schon konfiguriert
und sowas. Mal gucken. Ich denke mal, das wird in Zukunft
noch ein bisschen wachsen. Aber das ist
echt nice. So, während das hier
rumrödelt, wobei ich mach nix.
Ich lass den jetzt erstmal in Ruhe
den Container bauen.
Der ist ja gleich fertig. Ist ja schon hier bei
Rust-Installation.
Ich hab sogar ein richtiges
gitignore-File, was passt für das
jeweilige Projekt.
Oder für die jeweilige Programmiersprache.
So, jetzt hat er den Container erstellt, jetzt muss er den Container noch starten und Rust Rover drauf installieren, macht er alles automatisch.
Anni, jo, lädt gerade noch runter.
So, dann connecten wir uns einmal mit unserer IDE in den Container rein, der jetzt gerade hochgefahren wurde.
Das muss man auch nur einmal machen.
Machen wir die IDE auf dem dritten Desktop auf.
Und dann zeige ich euch das Template.
Für das Template-File ist es ziemlich easy.
Also man kann damit noch viel mehr machen, als das, was ich jetzt mache.
Also Trust mit dem Projekt.
So und schon sind wir fertig.
Schon haben wir einen Container zum entwickeln hier oben, wo wir per SSH drauf verbunden sind.
Haben eine IDE, die in Container verbunden ist.
Okay, oder auch nicht.
Das hat gerade ein bisschen den Geist aufgegeben.
Warum auch immer.
Geil.
Nein, ich will jetzt kein Survey taken.
Dann verbinde ich mich halt gerade nochmal.
Ich will mit Rust Rover drauf.
Guck, jetzt muss er das auch nicht nochmal machen.
Weil er hat ja schon alles installiert.
Jetzt geht das schneller.
Gucken.
Wirst du es auf Arch testen?
Ne, ich werde CacheOS installieren.
Was hat...
Ah, habe ich vorhin Kernel-Update gemacht?
Da steht Git not found. Ja, das ist okay.
Also der hat
irgendwelche Schmerzen gerade.
Wisst ihr was?
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was er für Schmerzen hat.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, wir deleten das jetzt einfach mal.
Blazingly slow.
Wir wollen Bustrover haben.
Also er geht nicht gefaundet hat, ist egal.
Das
findet er nie.
Gucken wir mal, ob mein
Cache Download fertig ist.
Wo hab ich den runtergeladen?
Hier, Cache.
Ja, ist fertig runtergeladen.
So, öffnen wir die IDE noch einmal.
Jetzt hoffen wir mal, dass es jetzt funktioniert.
Keine Ahnung, was der für Schmerzen hatte.
Ja, jetzt geht's.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Fast.
Ja, was auch immer.
Jetzt geht's.
Muss man nicht verstehen.
Jetzt habe ich hier meine IDE und kann ganz normal
entwickeln, wie wenn ich das bei mir
auf der Kiste selbst hätte.
Der Timeout ist kaputt.
Was für ein Timeout?
Achso, nee, Modkes sind gerade nicht am Start.
Das ist was manuelles, auch wenn es nicht so aussieht.
Willst du Timeoutet werden?
Na komm, dann Timeout ich dich persönlich.
Damn.
aber jetzt darfst du wieder als trinken erinnert ich habe sich wieder end time outet
jetzt sind wir hier am start haben direkt unser projekt können das
runden dann bildet er hier auch gleich die raster anwendung
er macht halt nichts anderes wie in it ausgeben haben bild script klar am start wo man dann
statisches binary bilden alles quasi auf fällt es aus dem template raus wir haben sogar ein
fertiges koki jetzt haben wir hier die anwendung quasi schon direkt gebaut und wir haben sogar ein
fix und fertiges docker file kann sagen docker bild sagt bauter der baut sogar ein image mit
der anwenden beziehungsweise kopiert die anwendung noch mal in docker gegen aktuelle stable rust und
dann baut einen minimal image mit der anwendung drin das kommt alles aus dem template raus jetzt
und ich kann euch das gleiche noch mal für für gold sein für golf funktioniert im prinzip ganz
genauso warum ist der download so lahm guckt euch das mal an ist das das neue vodafone peering
was ist das für eine download geschwindigkeit
viel slack man
ja gut das gucken wir uns jetzt warte mal warte warte mal wir brechen das mal ab und starten es
neu vielleicht geht es dann schneller ach guck mal wir haben einen anderen server erwischt jetzt
Nee, nee, nee, nee, haben wir nicht.
Also aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist der Download
an der Stelle hier super lahm.
Warum auch immer, man weiß es nicht genau.
Das muss ich euch aber jetzt nicht zeigen,
weil das ist ein
Docker-Image, was da rausfällt, wo man nicht viel sieht.
Ach, guck mal, jetzt gibt er Gas hier.
Jetzt gibt er, jetzt.
Naja.
War halbwegs.
Ah, der Docker hat nicht schlimme Raid Limits bekommen.
Doch, aber nach dem zweiten Download sollte das noch nicht sein.
Ja, hier ging ja auch eben schnell.
Doch, Docker.
Aber haben die nicht ein bisschen wieder zurückgedreht, Raid Limits?
Bei Docker war es ja teilweise mal so schlimm, dass du im Endeffekt gar nichts mehr richtig runterladen kannst.
Haben die nicht wieder ein bisschen zurückgedreht?
Ich will mir eigentlich schon vor einem Jahr oder so.
So, genau, zack.
Jetzt baut er mir meine Rust-Anwendung hier im Container und macht Minimal-Image draus.
Jetzt kommt halt alles aus dem Template rausgefallen, was ich extrem nice finde.
Dann werde ich jetzt einfach mal für alle Sachen, die ich so verwende, werde ich mir da so ein Projekt-Template anlegen.
Weil wenn man es nochmal braucht, zack.
fertig und schon haben wir docker run
mit der anwendung trainer container image so löschen wir das mal dann noch mal
cookie cutter go template ist im prinzip genau das gleiche go champ null heißt das projekt jetzt
jetzt aber auch zack hier alles drin was wir brauchen bild script run script docker file
kann ich auch gleich hier sagen docker bild und jetzt lädt er mir das go image runter und baut
mir meine go anwendung alles kommt das aus dem template raus def container geschichten habe ich
auch wieder jetzt will ich mich hier mit goland connecten macht er im prinzip genau das gleiche
wie bei dem anderen Image auch. Nur dass er jetzt GoLand installieren muss. So, dann kann ich euch
jetzt mal das Template zeigen, während er hier GoLand runterlädt, wie das aussieht, weil an
sich ist das relativ easy gemacht. Ich lasse den gerade noch mal hier fertig durchlaufen,
dass wir das dann wieder zumachen können.
Und dann hauen wir mal
CacheOS rein.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt heute kein Test,
ob man da drauf gescheit spielen kann oder so.
Da muss ich das mal auf der
auf dem Minisforum PC hier installieren
und nicht in der VM.
Sondern ich will mir einfach mal wieder KDE angucken.
Also das, was ich von KDE noch im Kopf habe, ist, und das ist wie gesagt, ich habe KDE zuletzt vor 15 Jahren oder so verwendet, ist, du hast bei KDE 50.000 Untermenüs und kannst 3000 Sachen einstellen, überall. Das ist so das, was ich mir von KDE gemerkt habe.
Warum geht Goland nicht?
Was ist hier los?
Cannot start IDE.
Was hat er für Schmerzen
gehabt gerade?
Kommen wir mal hier zu.
Was hat er für Schmerzen gerade gehabt?
Das muss ich gerne mal ausprobieren.
Warum geht das denn?
Ist Go-Land gerade kaputt oder?
Nö.
Jetzt geht's. Okay, keine Ahnung,
was er für Schmerzen hatte.
Aber da sind wir jetzt drauf.
Haben hier unser Go-Projekt.
Alles am Start.
So, und hier drinnen auch wieder
einfach schon alles
vorkonfigurieren. Das muss man dann nur noch starten.
So. So sieht das aus.
Delete.
Löschen wir den hier auch noch.
So, wie so ein Template aussieht, ist folgendes. Ich habe hier einen Template-Ordner.
Da gibt es Template für jede Programmiersprache, wie ich bis jetzt angelegt habe.
Ein Template für Rust, ein Template für Go und ein Base-Template.
Gucken wir erstmal in das Base rein. Base gibt es im Prinzip drei Sachen.
Ein Base-Docker-File. Das wird quasi dann immer bis hierhin verwendet.
Danach kommt das Programmiersprachenspezifische.
Also ich nehme immer einen Debian-Trixi, installiere immer das gleiche Zeug,
installiert konfigurieren user immer gleich da muss man das dann jedes mal irgendwie rein copy
pasten installieren kauf installierte nix us package manager drauf für zusatzsoftware genau
so sieht das so sieht das base mäßig aus korn ist ein skript was gebastelt habe was im endeffekt
ab fragt welche idee man verwenden will und das dann über der spot startet das ist jetzt sehr
spezifisch für mich das ist jetzt nichts allgemeines und dann haben wir noch eine
dev container jason ist auch für jedes projekt gleich so und da sieht man schon
was cookie cutter macht das stellt über so template strings variablen bereit wo
man dann seine einzelnen repos da customizen kann
hier setzt er beispielsweise den projektname ein ginger2 template syntax
Und dann gehen wir jetzt mal rein, beispielsweise hier bei Rust.
Und letztendlich hat man dann hier eine Cookie Cutter, Jason.
Da ist sonst nichts aktuell drin, außer dass man, das sind die Sachen, die rein abfragt bei Projekterstellung.
Man kann auch eine Auswahl machen, man kann auch quasi sowas hier machen.
Irgendwie, blub, und dann kann man quasi hier auswählen lassen.
1, 2, 3 oder sowas.
Und dann kriegt man im Projekterstellungsdialog so eine Auswahl,
wo man dann auswählen kann, was man haben will.
Und hier ist halt das Verzeichnis.
Das ist auch mit so einem Template String, wie es dann heißt.
Hier gibt es nochmal einen Template Ordner für projektspezifische Sachen.
Da ist einfach nur das Docker Base File nochmal reingesümlingt.
Und hier ist dann halt...
Kann man schlecht Auto completen.
Hier ist dann halt der ganze Cample drin, wie es im Projektverzeichnis nach dem Template rauskommt.
Und das sieht man auch hier in der Readme ist auch nochmal die Variable zum Einsetzen drin.
Und sonst liegt da halt ganz spezifisch der Grab.
Der einzige Unterschied ist hier das Dockerfile für die Dev-Container.
Da kannst du hier oben sagen, include Dockerfile base.
Und dann habe ich da nur noch das projektspezifische.
Oder das Programmiersprachenspezifische.
Man könnte, man kann sogar in diesem, in dieser Cookie Cutter Chasen, kann man dann auch abfragen, so nach dem Motto, was für eine Projektart soll es denn sein? Ein CLI Projekt, ein Web Projekt und sonst was und man kann das dann unterschiedlich templaten.
ist eigentlich ein ganz
nices Projekt
hab ich noch nie gesehen vorher
ich bin da nur drauf gekommen, weil ich
mit morgen überlegt hab, ey, gibt's nicht
irgendwie so ein Template Tool, was dir
schon neue Projekte generieren kann
aus schon bestehenden, da hab ich das gefunden
es gibt auch noch jede Menge andere solcher Software
aber das hat einen ganz guten Eindruck gemacht
und es ist halt bei Arch in den Standard
Repos mit drin
eigentlich sehr nice
exzellent. Oder was sagt ihr?
Also ich finde das
gut. Mal gucken, wie weit
ich mich da dran gewöhne.
Ich habe ja schon immer mal wieder coole Tools
gefunden, wo ich dann zu faul war, die zu benutzen.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Aber ich glaube, das ist ganz gut.
Und wenn ich dann irgendwann mal eine
ordentliche Anzahl an Templates habe,
dann
kann ich die auch mal auf GitHub
pushen.
Was nimmst du für die Devcontainer? Devpod, ja. Guck, sieht man auch hier. Hier reingehen. Devcontainer. Ich hab hier so ein Connect-Skript, was ein bisschen Magic im Hintergrund macht.
ja aber letztendlich macht irgendwann auch mal eine devport ab nachdem man sich man kann sich
aus der liste hier eine idee aussuchen oder sogar zwei die man connecten will dann connectet er die
und connectet sich abschließend noch einmal per ssh drauf und leitet port 8080 weiter falls es
eine web anwendung ist aber letztendlich ist es ist es der pot ja und das funktioniert echt gut
dann installieren wir das sommer und wenn es mir gefällt dann installiere ich das auch mal
auf Hardware.
Also.
Custom.
Moment, ist die Musik zu laut?
Wie sie, hä?
Aber geht eigentlich.
Welche VMA Workstation Version hast du?
Die allerneueste.
Die dir jetzt auch nichts mehr kostet.
Ich habe meine alte, die ich gekauft habe,
benutze ich nicht mehr.
Warum auch?
Das einzige Problem, was ich habe
unter Windows 11 mit vor allem
der Workstation.
Wieso hat die Probleme?
Gibt es einen Grund, warum die 17er besser ist?
Das einzige Problem,
was ich unter Windows 11 damit habe,
ist, dass man da,
wenn man die ganzen Windows Security Features
anlassen möchte,
muss man Hyper-V
unter der Haube verwenden.
Das ist halt...
Okay, also.
Installiere niemals KDE-Applications
Meta of Arch. Mit dem bekommst du
alle KDE-Programme.
Wie viel Platz braucht das?
Brauchst du schon ein bisschen, oder?
installer disk
download cacios linux cache gibt es auf was ist das archlinux ist das cashier basis moment
Moment mal, man kann hier gar keine A-Anschienung auswählen.
Ja, dann muss ich wieder mal das übliche auswählen.
CacheOS.
Next.
So, vier CPU... Ach komm, sechs CPU-Kerne.
Sehen wir mal nicht so knauselig.
Und...
16 gig ram muss ja ein bisschen ein bisschen power next next next create new virtual disk
80 gig sollte jetzt erst mal zum testen reichen custom als hardware soundkarte raus prominent
Fest lassen wir so.
Steinadler, Dankeschön für den
Submassive
Subscription.
So, dann haben wir das.
Dann starten wir das doch mal.
Das Inkaki-Kata-Project-Name war ja das dann.
Ja.
Du meinst, dass du quasi so eine
Kacki...
Was hab ich mit Kacki-Cutter, Alter?
Cookie-Cutter
Du willst eine Cookie-Cutter-Base haben?
Das weiß ich nicht
Also eine Cookie-Cutter-Jason-Base
Keine Ahnung, ob sowas geht
Aber es wird ja wahrscheinlich nicht so...
Letztendlich wird Projektname überall gleich sein.
Und die Sachen, die man zusätzlich braucht, sind ja eh unterschiedlich.
Vielleicht geht das. Keine Ahnung.
Also doch, das geht. Das geht.
Hab ich sogar gelesen bei denen.
Du kannst eine globale Config anlegen mit Standardwerten.
Ach nee, das bringt dir ja nix.
Da muss man gucken.
Was mache ich?
Side-Channel-Mitigations.
Brauch man nicht.
Ich will keine Side-Channels mitigaten.
Wo kann man diesen Mist nochmal ausschalten?
Das war hier irgendwie in der Options Advanced.
Side-Channel.
Ja.
Nichts geside-channelt.
cash ios default
fallback new york default kinder gut release input die weg
okay man sieht gleich dass ein archie nux ist
Kein UEFI?
Stimmt, du hast recht
Das muss
Ja, ja, ja, ja, das ist richtig
Das muss direkt
Warum hat er eigentlich standardmäßig
Nicht UEFI drin, wo war der?
Zack, aber Secure Boot werden wir nicht enablen
Ich benutze Windows und Linux
Beides
Warum sieht der Bootloader unter UEFI so viel beschissener aus?
Was macht er da gerade?
Rebuild Dynamic Linker Cache.
Waiting until kernel time synchronized.
What?
Okay.
Boss Champ?
Ah, da sind wir.
Live User.
Passwort.
There is no password.
Okay.
Ich soll die Session
Changen? Wie changed man die Session?
Okay. Hä? Was war das jetzt?
Was jetzt?
Wie jetzt? Was, was, äh...
Moment.
Ach, X funzt gar nicht standardmäßig.
Oder was? Warum ist es denn standardmäßig ausgewählt?
So, da sind wir.
Ah, ich hab noch was vergessen, Leute.
Ich hab noch was vergessen. Wir müssen noch mal kurz ausschalten.
Ich hab das Wichtigste...
Das Wichtigste hab ich vergessen, dass das gescheit funktioniert.
Display, use accelerated graphics.
Das muss man einschalten, sonst ist es wahrscheinlich ziemlich lahm.
Okay, jetzt muss er nochmal den Dynamic Linker Cache rebuilden.
irgendwelche
Cachy-Dinger.
Hat er geschafft.
Äh.
Boss Champ?
Hat er es eben auch so lange gebraucht?
Seid ihr schon drin, Chat?
Jetzt.
Change to Wayland.
Next.
Da sind wir.
Ups.
Ja, jetzt geht auch schon besser.
Also.
Welcome to CacheOS.
Warten wir mal was.
Oh, warum ist mein?
Warum ist mein Mauszeiger gerade so fett geworden?
Ist das immer, wenn man Firefog startet, wird dann immer der Mauszeiger fett?
Ne.
Just wailing things.
Zu viel gewackelt? Achso.
Ah.
Oh.
Massive Pfeifett.
Wie fett kann der noch werden?
Kann der noch fetter werden?
Ich glaube, jetzt ist
Maximum Pipo Fett erreicht.
Guck mal.
Der wird immer fetter noch.
Es wird immer dicker.
Er passt schon gar nicht mehr auf den Bildschirm.
Man könnte für den Mauszeiger übrigens eigentlich auch Vektorgrafik verwenden, oder?
Dann wäre er nicht so pixellig.
Leute, der ist super fett jetzt.
Ich lasse den mal los.
Was passiert jetzt?
Jetzt wird er wieder klein.
Okay.
View.
Exclusive Mode.
Google.
KI-Modus.
Okay.
Läuft eigentlich relativ flüssig hier, muss man sagen, ja.
So, dann.
Boah, was haben wir denn hier unten noch Schönes?
Der File Manager.
Das sieht fast aus wie Tuna.
Nur, dass es Dolphin ist.
Früher hieß das Ding doch nicht Dolphin unter KDE.
War das nicht Nautilus?
Nee, Nautilus war Gnome früher, ne.
Dann habe ich vergessen, wie das Ding...
Crusader gab es früher noch.
Als File Manager.
So, dann installieren wir doch mal.
Wo ist Launch Installer?
Was sind das hier unten?
Was haben wir dann sonst noch?
System Settings, Application Launcher.
Das machen wir jetzt, weil es installiert ist.
Guck mal, das ist ein Startmenü, wo tatsächlich sowas wie Kategorien existieren und wo man wahrscheinlich auch Sachen, naja nicht wirklich, aber man kann es, okay das geht nicht.
Das hätte ich jetzt gedacht, dass Funst, dass man Sachen irgendwie in Favoriten track und droppen kann.
Add to Favorites, Favorites, Favorites, Favorites, oh okay.
Kann man die Dinger hier wenigstens track und droppen?
Wenn ich jetzt sage, okay, das da will ich auch zu Favorites.
Ja, guck mal.
Man kann Sachen im Startmenü track und droppen.
Da kann es Windows noch was von abschneiden.
Okay, also was haben wir?
Choose a bootloader.
Was zum Teufel ist AISDK?
Was ist AIS?
Was zum Teufel hat das mit dem Bootloader zu tun?
Installs CUDA, Olamacuda und
config.
Aber
Was zum teufel hat ist die kam mit bootloader zu tun ich aber was hat das mit dem bootloader zu tun
das macht doch an der stelle überhaupt keinen sinn
Es ist system debut alles klar
Willkommen zum Installationsprogramm
für CacheUS
Okay, wir machen das zumindest nicht in Deutsch, sondern
in Esperanto
Wie wärs mit Englisch, Leute?
Englisch?
Einfach Englisch?
Warum gibt's kein Englisch?
geht ja schon amerikanisch okay das geht ja schon gut los britisch englisch besser
wenn der bootloader ein fehler wirft kann er einen agent start um es zu fixen ja ganz bestimmt
Next.
Okay, vergrößern sollte man es nicht,
das sieht letztlich aus.
Europe, Berlin.
Pass auf, gleich wieder IP-Leak oder irgendwie sowas.
So.
German.
No Dead Keys.
Erase Disk.
Jawohl. Hau drauf.
Gib ihm 8 Schick.
Dafür hast du ja eine extra Platte.
Ah.
Encrypt System.
Das kannst du auch direkt auswählen.
Das machen wir doch mal.
Super Highly Secure Passwort, Leute.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Da kommt nie einer drauf.
Next.
Jetzt kann man auswählen.
Plasma Desktop.
Okay, Plasma ist KDE.
Warum heißt KDE nicht mehr KDE?
Sondern warum heißt es jetzt Plasma?
Da stimmt mein Streamtitel doch gar nicht.
Den muss ich umbenennen in KDE Plasma.
Oma gibt aber ganz schön viel...
Was ist...
Ugui!
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Similar to Windows 7.
Wavefire.
sehr gut hat möglich war es wie es ist quasi drei für weyland aber konnte ich
nie konnte ich die ordentlich verwenden openbox das ja guck mal hier für unsere
die reeps openbox ich habe früher flux box verwendet mit hammer auch
ich verwende i3 auch weiterhin lx qt lxd ist lx qt nicht die weiterentwicklung von lx die war
das nicht so dass irgendwie lxd nicht mehr gibt hier die hyperland i3 cosmic
Es gibt da auch schon ganz schön viel Krempel.
Weil Raylan in der VM immer rumgebackt hat
bis jetzt.
So.
No Desktop.
Lass mal.
Next.
Packages.
Cash US Package.
Ja gut, das kann man nachher immer noch alles machen.
Das ist gut.
Wisst ihr, ich finde den Installer schon mal ganz gut.
Das erschlägt dich einfach nicht.
Damit.
mit 30.000 sachen wo gerade nix mit anfangen können das doch vollkommen
fein hier einfach auswählen sagt das sagt standardmäßig passt alles
printing support
konnte ich testen ob mein drucker funktioniert
installieren wir mal printing support mit interessiert mich ob mein drucker tut
Next.
Your full name. Cute chat. Massive Passwort.
Use the same password for the administrator account. Highly secure password.
So, jetzt zeigt er mir nochmal wie das ganze partitioniert wird.
Okay. Ich finde es übrigens auch gut, dass CacheOS standardmäßig ein Dark Mode hat.
Das ist genau richtig für mich.
Excellent.
Ist das excellent.
Install.
Install now.
Mal gucken, wie schnell das jetzt installiert.
In der VM geht es potenziell immer ein bisschen schneller.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Was soll das bedeuten?
Oder macht mein Browser-Plugin schlapp und da sollte jetzt irgendwas anderes stehen?
Warum funktioniert das?
Warum geht das nicht?
Hat FFZ das ausgeschaltet oder sowas?
Ne, das hat jetzt funktioniert.
Hä?
Warum geht das und...
Verstehe nicht.
Du musst FFZ installieren im Browser.
Oh.
Was jetzt?
Geht ja gut los.
Was hat er?
Hex Trap hat gefailt.
Yes.
Jetzt habe ich mein Install-Log
Okay
Jetzt können wir uns das Log hier angucken
Muss ich natürlich erstmal uploaden
Sieht man da jetzt irgendwas?
Kalamares.
Ähm.
Fail to retrieve some files.
Fail to install packages.
Moment.
Open SSL read?
Was?
Fail to retrieve file?
Habe ich Probleme im Internet?
Zugang?
Oder was ist da los?
Das hier ging und dann ging es auf einmal nicht mehr.
Okay, ganz ehrlich, ich...
Ich tippe auf irgendwas Temporäres.
Wir machen das einfach nochmal.
dumm dass man jetzt wieder alles von vorne machen muss
das zum debut also es lag auf jeden fall am download und ansonsten nix
so hin wir wollen britisch englisch
Ja man, no dead keys.
Erasedisk, Encrypt System.
Oder ist vielleicht einfach mein Passwort zu secure?
Das hat er nicht ausgehalten, for security.
Genau, das wird's sein
Das lag bestimmt an mir
Weil ich gestern die SSL-Zertifikate
Nicht ausgetauscht hab, fuck
Weißt du was, ich lass Printing-Support weg
Vielleicht war's das ja
Okay, install.
Install now. Bam.
Kann man da zugucken, was er macht? Aha.
Hier kann man zugucken.
In der Augenweide ist das Lock jetzt auch nicht gerade.
Es ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie eine Cute-Anwendung.
Guck mal, der testet immer noch die Mirrors.
Also, das hat er eben bestimmt auch gemacht und hat den besten Mirror gefunden.
Nur, dass das nicht der beste Mirror war.
So, jetzt kommt der Download.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Das sieht jetzt besser aus.
Guck mal, jetzt ist er schon bei irgendwelchen
Kernel-Geschichten, die installiert werden.
Error? Was?
Ich glaube, jetzt ist er fertig.
Ne, jetzt kommt nochmal.
Jetzt kommt nochmal ein Download.
Meint ihr es lag an den Drucker-Packages?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube der Mirror war einfach Schrott.
Den er da zufällig gepickt hat.
Lasing the fast installation.
Ich will das mit dem Drucker auch nachher mal ausprobieren.
Weil das müsste super funktionieren.
Ich habe so, ich habe einen Brother Laserdrucker, Farblaserdrucker.
Irgend so ein Standard PostScript Ding und das müsste gehen.
Ich bin noch keine Stunde am installieren.
Ach jetzt, jetzt, guck mal jetzt kommt das nochmal.
Da ist er das letzte Mal abgekackt.
Windows ist bei vielem Crap, unter anderem auch bei Druckertreibern.
Ok, jetzt scheint es aber zu funktionieren.
Da war vorher gar nichts kaputt, sondern der Mirror war einfach Schrott.
Mal gespannt, was wir da für Default-Programme haben.
Ich finde das ja gerade für Noobs immer wichtig, dass es eine ordentliche Selection an Default-Programmen
gibt und jetzt nicht 30.000 dass das startmenü aufmacht und reinguckt und
denkt ich habe jetzt acht verschiedene taschenrechner jetzt das wurscht ich
mache es eher am liebsten so minimal installation und dann selbst installieren
aber das machen wir heute mal explizit nicht
Die schleppen in Windows 11
noch richtig altes Zeug mit rum.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel bei Windows 11,
was alte Sachen angeht, ist immer das hier.
Das habe ich euch ja schon ein paar Mal
gezeigt hier. Change Icon.
Was da teilweise...
Also man kann... Dieses Fenster kann man übrigens
auch nicht resizen.
Also Leute, da sind teilweise
Icons drin.
Die sind aus die sind von windows windows 1 zeiten noch
Guck dir das mal an das ist das ist einfach mal legit windows windows 3 11
Ich weiß auch gar nicht warum sie so hässlich
hier siehst du richtig schön die windows teilweise der letzten 20 jahre so weil die
eigen styles ja immer zum jeweiligen us gepasst haben sieht dort teilweise komplett so out of
place aus so cash installiert dann und jetzt wie es da reboot
dann war
Cache, Moment, ich kann Linux Cache OS starten und Linux Cache OS LTS.
Ich habe zweimal was ins...
Ach ne, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur die Kernel-Version.
Jetzt habe ich es gecheckt.
Im LTS-Kernel.
Ach Quatsch.
Arch, by the way, pleading edge.
Postchamp?
Was ist hier los?
Chat.
Kann es sein, dass es nicht funktioniert?
Ups.
Es geht schon gut los.
Mit Sachen, die nicht aktualisiert werden.
Oh, krasser Prompt hier.
Exclusive Mode.
Aha.
Also optisch ist das damit schlecht, muss man sagen.
Guck mal, jetzt wackeln wir mal.
Das ist ein geiles Feature, das gefällt mir.
Da sehe ich mich schon, wenn es mir irgendwie langweilig ist, pumpe ich eine Stunde lang den Cursor auf.
Cryptoboot dauert doch gar nicht wirklich nennenswert länger.
Oh, es hat Passwort-Item.
Launch at Start.
Nee, das brauchen wir nicht.
Das müssen wir nicht at Start launchen.
Guck mal, na Moment mal.
Apps Tweaks.
Ah, nein.
Was?
Okay.
CPP.
C++.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das enable lassen soll.
Cache Update Enabled.
Update Notifier Entry.
Ja, das ist doch nicht verkehrt.
OK, brauche ich Root, muss ich Root für sein.
Geht jetzt Terminal auf dafür.
Da flippen doch schon wieder die ganzen Noobs aus.
Oh nein, eine Konsole.
OMG, eine Konsole, ich drehe durch.
Das passt aber optisch nicht so schön dahin.
CashUS Package Installer, CashUS Kernel Manager, bisschen wie bei Manjaro.
das ist der package manager exiten wir wieder so da machen wir das mal zu oder
gucken wie wir hier was finden utilities warum ist das grün da unten
Warum ist das grün?
Weil es da irgendwas Neues gibt?
Weil es da...
Ach, by the way.
Okay, was auch immer.
Wim!
Standard. Wie immerhin.
Top.
Ah, ein schönes
Screenshot-Tool.
Sehr schön.
Das ist bestimmt ein Wayland-only
Ding, hä?
Spectacle.
Das ist nice.
New Recording.
Rectangular Region
Ja, das will ich jetzt unbedingt recorden
Record
Massive recorded
Und jetzt?
Recording fertig, abspielen
Web-M
Na gut, ein GIF wäre wahrscheinlich ein bisschen groß
ja das gefällt mir gibt's spectacle gibt es das für mich checken github spektakel
das ist irgendwas anderes
anderes.
Screenshot Capture Utility.
Doch, die sind bei GitHub anscheinend.
Das ist...
Spectacle can also be used in non-KDE X11 desktop environments.
Okay, Moment, Sekunde, Leute.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Das gefällt mir nämlich.
Ich mach mal kurz einen Snapshot.
Das installiere ich mir jetzt hier auch mal.
Das ist nochmal hier.
das ist er da lernt man immer wieder neue sachen kennen aber mal neue distros und sachen ausprobiert
so sind es erleben jetzt mal hier unter arzt bei the way und dann gucken wir mal ob spectacle
auch unter i3 funktioniert.
Ups.
Ich bin wieder da. Ich habe meinen Bildschirm gelockt
aus Versehen.
Ich hoffe, es putzt doch alles.
Hört ihr mich noch?
Test, Test, Test. Ja, geht noch.
Ihr hört mich nicht.
Ah, shit.
So, also Spectacle.
Taktik
Hd
Erstmal 5000 sachen installieren ja gut 600 mb aller
Sommer ich bin jetzt bitte meint ihr das tut unter und unter i3 ordentlich
Das was meint ihr ich habe da meine zweifel ehrlich gesagt ich glaube nicht dass es richtig gescheit funktioniert
Spektakel.
Naja.
Das funzt.
Das ist gut, das funzt.
Accept.
Geht.
ja das ist nicht schlecht
kann man jetzt hier vielleicht auch ein paar
Config Sachen einstellen, Options
Configure
Video Saving
kann man auch als GIF speichern
Das wäre richtig geil.
Geht aber glaube ich nicht.
Ach hier kann man.
Aber hier kann man nicht auswählen.
Es gibt nur WebM.
Aber das ist ein nice Tool.
Da kann man echt nichts sagen.
Also das ist echt gut.
Das kannte ich noch nicht.
Mal gucken, ob Screen Recording auch funzt.
Oh, hier ist Screen Recording.
Export.
Ich wollte eigentlich Screen Recorden.
Spektiker.
recording ist kaputt
recording geht bei mir nicht ich glaube ich glaube recording ist brauchen guck wieder mal
lass mal gucken wie das unter cash us ist da sagt spectacle green shot tool new recording
Aha, guck mal.
Das funzt nicht.
Warum?
Zuerst Select?
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich kann sogar hier auswählen.
Direkt, wenn ich es anklicke.
Ein YouTube-Video gibt es auch irgendwann noch.
Ach, guck mal.
Hier kann man sogar ein GIF einstellen.
Top.
Ich mag das Programm. Das gefällt mir.
New Recording.
Rectangular Region.
Record.
Blub, blub, blub.
Ups.
Und jetzt abbrechen.
Ja gut, GIF ist immer ein bisschen laggy.
Aber das ist ein High Quality GIF.
Warum funzt Spectacle?
Da muss ich jetzt mal...
Ups.
Naja.
Da muss ich jetzt mal kurz bei mir checken.
Hat er irgendwie gesagt, ich kann jetzt noch zusätzlich was installieren?
Optional Dependency.
Was brauche ich denn da?
Spektakel?
Vielleicht Video oder so?
Nee, das Popup, das geht ja, guck, wenn ich sage, wenn ich hier sage New Screenshot, geht das hier ohne Probleme, aber New Recording ploppt gar nichts auf.
Und man sieht auch in den Settings, dass ich hier nichts einstellen kann, so als fehlen Codex oder sowas.
So, pass auf, wir fragen jetzt mal
die KI.
Was muss ich
machen, damit Spectacle
unter Arch
E3
kann?
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Das wird nichts dazu wissen.
Wow, wie viele 100 neuen Webseiten, Alter.
Unter Anstellungs mit den Windows-Manager-Unit ist die derzeit nicht direkt nutzbar.
Ach, warum nicht?
Wayland-Exklusivität.
Ach, Video geht nur unter Wayland.
sätke sätke sätke sätke
uninstall
Ich kann nicht auf Wähler wechseln, das funktioniert in der VM gescheit.
Ich habe es schon ein paar Mal ausprobiert.
Immer gab es Probleme, dass es nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Das hier funktioniert allerdings erstaunlich gut, aber das liegt wahrscheinlich an der guten Implementierung von den KDE-Leuten.
Jetzt backt es wieder in der VM rum, Alter.
Das ist richtig für den Arsch.
So.
Okay, aber Spectacle gefällt mir.
Finde ich sehr nice.
So, jetzt lassen wir uns mal den Kram hier angucken.
Wie installiert man denn hier was?
Oder gucken wir uns erstmal an, was ist denn vorkonfiguriert.
Kate ist jetzt definitiv nicht der Texteditor meiner Wahl.
Habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Melt kenne ich.
Da kann man Files diffen und sowas mit. Standard Qt Dinger würde ich gerne hier ausblenden.
Graphics, Simple Image Viewer.
Ah gut.
Das ist sehr minimalistisch, was mir gut gefällt.
Internet, nur Firefox am Start und KDE Connect.
Multimedia, MPV.
haruna habe ich noch nie gehört was ist das für ein player
ein mann projekt
auch von den kde leuten system haben wir okay da gibt es ein terminal aller krit ist auch
nicht mein Lieblingsterminal.
Kann man aber sicherlich nehmen.
Better FS Assistant.
B-Top++ mag ich nicht.
Leute, ich sag euch ganz ehrlich,
wie es ist. Ich bin
H-Top-Enjoyer.
Das ist mir
zu fancy.
Das ist mir zu fancy.
H-Top-Beste.
Was macht denn der Wörter-FS-Assistant?
Äh
Das wirkt wie irgendwas, wo ich nicht
drinnen rumklicken will. Ah, Snapper
Stimmt, man hat standardmäßig Snapshots
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus
Das probieren wir mal aus, das habe ich nämlich auch gehört
dass Cache angeblich Snapshots anlegen kann automatisch bei einem Package Update oder bei einem Kernel Update oder irgendwie sowas.
Macht man das? New?
Ja, das hast du verwechselt.
B-Cache-FS ist das, der sich da mit Linus auch rumgestritten hat und sowas.
Wetter-FS ist schon ewig im Körnel und Funster auch ganz gut.
Hat bei mir so im Hinterkopf so ein bisschen dieses Entwicklung ist eingeschlafen.
Weiß gar nicht, ob das stimmt.
Ich weiß nur, dass jahrelang bei dem Raid 5 Modus dabei stand,
verwendet kein raid 5 das ist zwar verfügbar aber unstable wo ich mir denke so alter ernsthaft
seit irgendwie acht jahren oder so snapper settings ich mache das jetzt einfach mal ich
habe keine ahnung davon was das new backup path home home reicht mir moment
Home ist ein eigenes Volume.
die lied wäre jetzt glaube ich nicht so gut oder
und fickt ok blubb keine ahnung backup path alles snapper timeline das ist halt so ein bisschen was
warum das ist ein ding warum ich keine gui programme aber ob ich kein fan der meisten
wie programme bin das hat immer so den anstrich von es ist benutzerfreundlich
aber ganz ehrlich kein mensch ohne dass er das handbuch liest weiß was das hier ist
und das finde ich bei terminal programm viel angenehmer da sage ich minus minus help
ergibt kein maus auf und auch kein erklärer ding
was ich dann wüsste ich jetzt überhaupt nicht was das was das macht ehrlich gesagt ja
aber wir was trotzdem aus also config name blub backup passt das sniper timeline enabled ich
Okay, wir können ja mal was gucken.
Cache OS Snapper.
Okay.
Wie richte ich Snapper richtig ein?
Keck Wait, Alter.
Das ist mir schon wieder zu high IQ.
Arch Tutorial.
Beste.
Snapper Package.
Create Config.
Path to Subvolume.
Backup-Path
Ah, okay, jetzt verstehe ich
Ich glaube, ich glaube
Slash backupt nicht
Home mit
Das ist immer nur hier
Die Sub-Volumes
Sieht zwar ein bisschen blöd aus, aber wisst ihr
Wie ich meine? Also ich glaube, das ist
Immer wirklich immer diese Sub-Volume, also Slash
Includet nicht das andere
das ist genauso wie diese automatische translation chat von youtube videos das
kanzler ausschaltet da müsste nämlich irgendeiner der der low iq leute die
das verbrochen hat zugeben dass es doch nicht die geilste funktion ever ist okay was ist timeline
it can create and compare snapshots revert between
central and supports automatic snapshots timelines
Okay, wir machen das jetzt einfach
Enable Snapper Timeline, bam
Save
Apply Systemd Changes
Snapper Boot
Ich weiß nicht so genau, was ich da mache
aber das machen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Enable Timeline Snapshots.
Okay, 10.
Ah.
Oh, das ist cool.
Das ist fast so gut wie
4M Snapshots. Guck mal,
der macht jetzt 10 Snapshots in der Stunde.
10 Stück Daily.
Das ist also
wie viel er aufhebt, würde ich auch mal sagen, oder?
Und für 10 Jahre
rückwärts.
Für 10 Monate.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Save.
So.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt kann ich auch mal von Hand eins anlegen.
Hier.
Blub.
Manual Snapshot.
Okay.
Und kann ich das jetzt restauren?
Aus meinem Bootmanager raus?
Weil wenn ich mir jetzt das System zerschossen habe,
dann bringt es mir ja nichts.
Das war automatisiert? Echt? Wirklich?
Naja.
Also.
Ich habe jetzt einen Snapshot gemacht.
Jetzt rebooten wir mal.
Und dann gucken wir mal,
ob im Crab irgendwas ist.
Nee.
Ja, das ist natürlich...
Okay, damit müsste man sich nochmal genauer beschäftigen.
Es packt übrigens rum, dieses Verschlüsselungsding.
Damit müsste man sich nochmal genauer beschäftigen.
Ja, dann halt System D booten.
Mir ja wurscht.
Aber irgendwo müsste man das ja beim Booten schon auswählen können,
wenn ich jetzt mein System zerschossen habe.
Ups.
Monke S.
Äh, wir sind...
Ah, System Deboot kann das also nicht.
Das müsste man natürlich vorher wissen.
Aber dann ist es ja doof, dass das das Default ist.
Okay, das probieren wir nachher.
Installieren wir nochmal neu.
Wenn wir mal rumprobiert haben und gucken, wie das mit den Snapshots ist.
Also das war auf jeden Fall nicht mehr am Start launchen.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier zu bieten?
Cachy Hello. Ach, das ist dieses Ding.
Packages and Hardware.
Infocenter.
Octopi.
Octopi ist für 3D-Drucker.
Äh.
Nee.
Chat, jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Warum gibt es jetzt das und das?
Das sind jetzt nicht zwei verschiedene Package-Manager?
Einfach für Pac-Man?
Konsole?
konsolen konsolen ist auch dabei und aller kritik auch
das sieht auf jeden fall besser gerendert aus aber ich würde west verwenden
bisschen ein bisschen zu krasse transparanz oder hubs was bisschen zu
heftig die transparenz vom terminal finde ich das ist ja fast nichts
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Menü-Editor.
Manage Scheduler.
Was bin ich sehend?
Was?
SCX Beerland.
Ich stell da mal nix dran rum.
Was magst du am liebsten?
Bash, ZSH oder ZZSH?
Zisch.
Liste Monitor.
Fix.
Was?
Was hat er?
Ach, die haben Fisch.
Aha.
Okay, das gefällt mir defaultmäßig nicht.
Aber das ist ja nichts, was man nicht ändern kann.
System Settings.
Das sind die KDE Settings.
Die Standard KDE Settings.
Emoji Selector.
Ganz wichtig.
Ist da auch
Jawohl.
Pregnant Men.
Die sind top aktuelle Emojis.
Haben sie.
Und die Gans.
Okay, die haben wirklich den allerneuesten Emoji-Unicode-Standard.
Das sind die zwei Emojis, die man suchen kann.
Pregnant Man ist der vorletzte Standard und Goose ist der letzte Standard.
Ah, ich hab schon abgedreht, hä?
Was für ein Pregnant Man Emoji haben.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten?
Show Disk Usage?
Ah!
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen
Ich kenn das auch für 3D-Drucker
Ich hab auch Octopie hier für meinen 3D-Drucker installiert
Das hat mich auch verwirrt
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an Windiestat
Ich finde, ich benutze dieses Emote manchmal einfach als fetter Mann.
Anstelle, wenn es Pipo fett nicht gibt.
Aha, hier kann man Zeug aussehen.
Breeze.
Moment, ich habe nicht Breeze Dark ausgewählt.
Natürlich habe ich Dark.
Er meint, ich habe nicht Dark ausgewählt.
Priest.
Hä?
Der hat komisch.
Der hat Pepega-Zeug gemacht.
Wallpaper?
mit den standard hintergrund eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht
ich finde es jetzt nicht schlecht es hat ja noch ein paar unrunde ecken so aber jetzt gefällt mir
wir gucken gleich noch welcher package ich will mir gerade mal die settings angucken
wo kann ich meinen drucker einrichten
in octo pie in den set ach das geht direkt in den settings das probieren wir jetzt aus
Das testen wir jetzt.
Ich muss nochmal kurz checken.
Winter, was für eine IP mein Drucker hat.
Der ist offline.
Fuck, warum ist der offline?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Sekunde.
ok der dhcp server ließ es war der roter printer
zum teufel ist mein drucker wartet mal ich muss mal kurz zu meinem drucker und hat auf die nach
alpico
wieder da keine ahnung was der für schmerzen hatte aber ich wundere mich dass ich keine static
es ist ja wieder gehabt ich weiß woran es liegt alle ich kaknub ich habe dem noch eine feste ip
gegeben weil er immer probleme mit dhcp hatte wartet mal ping 121.224 jawolle ist der drucker
das ist der drucker jetzt weiß ich es wieder weil ich habe schon gewundert warum ich sie
beim dhcp nichts drin auch keine leases drin keine keine static leases drin ip liegt fuck
Chat, jetzt vorbei.
Habt ihr schon eure Bitcoins ausgedruckt auf meinem Drucker?
Wer sollte ihn auch so finden?
Der ist in einem anderen Netz.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der den findet.
Der ist im WLAN-Netz.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Global Theme.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Breeze Dark, Breeze Twilight.
ehrlich gesagt finde ich das standardding eigentlich gar nicht schlecht
ach so das ist schwarzes desktop design aber helle ordner
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nee.
Okay.
Haben wir nicht.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Nichts, nichts, nichts, nichts.
Sound juckt mich nicht.
Display Monitor juckt mich nicht.
Light, Light.
Ähm.
Kann man irgendwie sagen, dass der jetzt auf den Night-Modus switchen soll?
Einfach mal interessiert mich einfach, ob das funktioniert.
Always on Night.
Ah, cool.
Das funktioniert nämlich unter X nicht richtig.
Ach hier unten?
Ah ja.
Verstehe.
Also kann man jetzt quasi sagen
Sunrise, Sunset.
Ja gut, es ist jetzt ja schon
Nighttime.
ach sunset denk da ist 18 uhr based on your device location da sind wir exakt
wir sind hier irgendwo 15 uhr okay zack night mode an da mache ich das mal always off weil ich
finde es gerade ein bisschen zu anstrengend cool funktioniert echt alles so first try
Nein, nicht schlecht.
Online-Accounts, bravo, nett.
Animations, ganz wichtig.
Wobbly Windows.
Gibt's das hier.
Das Wichtigste eigentlich.
Und, soll mir recht sein.
Mir gefällt das.
Das hat was.
Das ist, glaube ich, wenn ich mal wirklich mein E3 nicht mehr verwenden kann,
finde ich KDE, so wie es jetzt ist, gar nicht übel.
Also, gefällt mir deutlich besser als modernes Gnome.
animations windows open close windows touch window full screen desktop effects
appearance windows behavior
Leute, Leute, da ist es
Es gibt's
Bäm, jawoll
Allerwichtigster Effekt
Huge
Wobbly Windows am Start, Alter
Er ist, okay, das System ist
gekauft
Ja, das Linux Desktop
ist am Start
Excellent
Das muss sofort eingeschaltet werden
Immer wenn es da ist
Da könnt ihr es, könnt ihr es mir stundenlang angucken.
Guck, wie es wobbelt, Alter. Wie es wobbelt.
Wie nice es wobbelt.
Was ich jetzt noch cool fände, so einen Windows Select Modus,
Wo man so eine Übersicht über die Fenster bekommt.
Okay, Virtual Desktops gibt es nur einen.
Da brauche ich auf jeden Fall mehr.
Ah, hier kann man dann dazwischen umschalten.
Gibt es eine Shortcut zum zwischen den Desktops umschalten?
Ne.
Äh, da leuchtet es.
Und was bringt das, wenn es leuchtet?
Die Maus leuchtet links oben
Das ist die Fensterübersicht
Aber
Das scheint gerade kaputt zu sein, oder?
Wie legt man...
Okay, da muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Wie würde man denn jetzt hier einstellen?
Shortcuts.
Wie würde ich jetzt hier beispielsweise Desktop-Switchen einstellen?
Accessibility?
Keyboard, ha? Keyboard.
Shortcuts.
Nee, ich will keine Application switchen.
Ich will...
Desktop switchen.
Plasma Workspace vielleicht?
Ne.
Virtual Desktop?
oben links.
Okay, ich sehe schon, das ist aber immer noch
typisch KDE. Man kann Gott
und die Welt einstellen. Das finde ich nice.
Das gefällt mir. Da blickt man jetzt nicht
instant bei allem
sofort durch, aber es ist schon...
Warum geht der Overview
nicht?
Hä?
Das ist irgendwie
broken, oder?
Das scheint gerade etwas
kaputt zu sein.
Machen wir hier oben
nochmal. Lockscreen.
So, mal gucken, ob das funzt. Okay, das
funzt.
Vielleicht ist das einfach oben links kaputt.
Das ist kaputt oben links.
Das ist broken. Oben links ist broken.
In der Mitte geht.
Oben links ist kaputt, das geht nicht.
Mitte geht.
Das ist ein Bug gerade.
Aber nee, ich hab vor allem
Exclusive-Modus an.
Das sollte eigentlich nicht reinfuschen.
Kann sein, glaub ich aber nicht.
Vielleicht komme ich einfach nur nicht weit genug links an die Ecke, dass er es checkt.
Aber er leuchtet ja.
Das müsst ihr eigentlich kapieren.
Aber machen wir mal...
Rechts oben Overview.
Okay, Ecken.
Leute, Ecken funsten nicht.
Das ist irgendeine Forever-Geschichte.
Irgendeine Forever-Geschichte muss das sein.
Gucken wir mal, wenn wir da...
Das ist irgendeine Forever-Geschichte.
Dass Ecken nicht funsten.
In der Mitte geht's.
Na gut, dann ist auch egal.
Aber was mich jetzt viel mehr interessieren würde, ist,
wie kann ich die desktops switchen ok konnte hat jemand im chat geschrieben
controller f1 f2 aber ich würde das gerne um belegen switch
ok dann suchen wir mal danach las mal change desktop shortcut
was unter shortcuts virtual desktop man hat man die window management ach so
wird
switch one desktop down switch one desktop to the left switch to desktop eins ok
task manager entry paul schnitt switch desktop 2
ha
ponzt desktop switch beste und wobbly windows am start exzellent exzellent wir probieren jetzt
noch mal was anderes aus und zwar hier wo war das war das mit wobbly desktop effekte hier oben kann
man noch neue desktop effekte gätten use korsen exe user kreate content
johnny asmr kontinente aha supply chain angriffe am start kann man das sortieren
nach rating nur die besten wie das ist alles
wer gibt's nicht
mehr desktop effekte gibt es nicht oder
da war kommt es damals immer noch besser aber das ist schon mal
nice brennende fenster würde ich auch sagen dass ich die braucht
Wir sagen Fire.
Ja.
Beste.
Inspired by Compits.
Jawohl.
Okay.
Install.
Bam.
Ok, Desktop Effects.
So, und jetzt hier, Fire.
Da.
Muss man vielleicht hier nochmal raus, dann nochmal rein.
Oh ja.
Effekts.
Wo ist es denn?
Oh, nice!
Das gibt's auch.
Beste.
Meta C.
Not Virtual Desktop.
Ha!
Ist das nicht.
Die Zukunft ist jetzt, Leute.
beste das ist so ein typischer effekt der ist einfach nur der ist einfach nur
nice zum eindruck machen nicht zum täglich benutzen
wo kann ich denn jetzt hier
Also ich kann das Feuer hier nicht aktivieren.
Also das steht hier nicht drin.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwelche nicen Effekts?
Was ist das?
Ha!
Ne, also anscheinend
funzt das bei mir nicht.
Mit dem...
Mit den Effekten.
Ich mach das nochmal kurz zu.
Settings.
Oder...
Effekt kann man auch direkt. Ups, Effekt. Ah, nice, kann man direkt suchen. Seht ihr irgendwo was von Fire?
Ne, Burn? Also das gibt es bei mir nicht. Ansonsten wüsste ich nicht, wo ich suchen soll.
Man kann jetzt noch das hier machen.
Also Fire-Effekt. Gut nicht.
Kannst du dann auch an zwei Fenstern gleichzeitig arbeiten?
Wie jetzt?
An den Store.
Du meinst jetzt hier so irgendwie...
Naja, du kannst ja immer nur einen Desktop aufhaben.
Also du kannst jetzt nicht...
Du kannst zwei Fenster jemals im Vordergrund auf dem jeweiligen Desktop haben.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist nur was für Show.
Das ist nur was für Show.
Das ist nichts, was irgendjemand ernsthaft benutzt, glaube ich, diesen Cube.
So, aber gefällt mir. Gefällt mir gut.
So, und jetzt wollte ich noch gucken.
Das mit den Snapshots haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
So was mein Drucker wollte ich ausprobieren Drucker.
Settings so angeblich geht es ja von hier sagt der Chat.
Wo denn?
Networking.
Hier sehe ich es nicht.
Print.
Hier kann man keinen Printer installieren.
Printing Support muss ich noch installieren.
Tja.
Wie installiere ich den Printing Support?
Schauen wir uns mal hier drüber.
Graphics in Office.
Okay.
Printing.
Print.
Hm.
Jedes druckerzeug ist installiert
Das konnte man dem installer auswählen habe ich aber nicht
Guck mal suchen war es install printing
KDE Plasma Printing.
Und wie ist das Licht?
Uuuh, mein Auge, Alter!
System Config Printer.
Scheint nicht.
Ach, hier ist alles drinne.
System Config Printer.
Das da?
ok ganz ehrlich der package manager weil sie jetzt dann war dann war ich das lieber
über das terminal wie gehabt printer settings gibt es jetzt hier sind das service ist nur
naja gut ich wollte ja eh nochmal neu installieren damit ich das mit den snapshots testen kann
im willkommensassistent ist das wieder drin
ok
zwar hier irgendwo
cash ios
das geht doch nicht leute es geht doch nicht das kann ich euch gleich sagen
der ist der ist der ist auch alle installiert
hieß dieses cash ding zum start cashie hallo ist das
install apps
install gaming package install snapper support dieses ganze manuelle zeug hätte
ich mir komplett schenken können.
ähm
bin ich blöd seh ichs nicht?
install printer support?
nix oder?
ich hab nix gesehen
Eins zurück und dann Apps.
Das da?
Ne, dann geht diese Package-Verwaltung auf.
Chat, ihr wisst es auch nicht besser.
dass das dass ich das über das kommentar ich dachte aber nur darum gibt es hier
nichts wenn es das ist ja doof wenn man das im installer auswählen kann und
dann nachträglich nicht aber wie gesagt ich wollte ich wollte neu installieren
mit einem anderen boot manager
machen jetzt aus der installe neu das dauert zwei minuten und dann installieren wir auch
gleich mit kraft und gucken ob das mit den snapshots funktioniert weil das interessiert mich
tatsächlich noch
äh, Boot
CD
oh, alter, es hat geleckt
es hat geleckt, habt ihr es gesehen?
geleckt hat es
alter
Warum leckt das so?
Alter, das leckt ja brutal.
Was?
Was zum?
Das ist bestimmt ein Bug von
VMware wieder.
Ich dreh durch.
Guckt euch das an.
Wie kaputt das Shit ist.
Jetzt, jetzt
jibbel ich sie.
backt er nicht mehr. Ich fass es nicht.
Jetzt backt er nicht mehr.
Ey.
Jetzt backt er beim Starten wieder.
Meine Güte, ey.
Sag mal.
Jetzt backt das wieder.
Ey, ich fass es nicht.
Wie beschissen kann man es in VMware...
Wie beschissen kann es VMware eigentlich noch machen, ey?
Jetzt geht's.
CD.
Meine Güte, Alter.
Ey, guck dir das an.
WTF? Was hat er denn jetzt gestartet überhaupt?
Ich raste aus, ey.
Ich dreh
komplett durch.
Wenn ich Enter drücke,
wiederholt er nochmal den letzten Druck.
Manchmal. Manchmal auch nicht.
Seht ihr was?
Nee, das muss, ey, das geht nicht.
Das machen wir nicht.
Löschen und neu, das machen wir nicht.
Aber das Starten schon.
Das machen wir nicht.
Leute, wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Wir machen jetzt die Hilfe-Support aus.
Dann geht es bestimmt.
Werde ich mit euch.
Ah, ich war zu langsam.
Easy, geht sofort.
Geht sofort.
CD-ROM-Drive.
Und sieht schöner aus.
Geht sofort.
UEFI backt wieder rum.
In der VM ist es ja auch vollkommen wurscht ob UEFI Support oder BIOS Legacy Support.
Cashewiki empfiehlt LimeMine für BTRFS und Snapshots booten funktioniert damit.
Machen wir.
Limline.
Limine.
limine aus champ
da nennen wir machen wir machen lieben ein weil habe ich noch nie benutzt
bis sie neues zeug sehen ist ja nicht verkehrt so launch installer
weil ich jetzt zu was anderes kann man kann man gar nicht auswählen wenn man
nicht so efi hat er okay da mal in die mine
Okay, machen wir mal hier schnell
British English
Next
Europe, next
German
No, that, ne, ne, ne
Erasedisk
Encrypt spare ich mir jetzt einfach mal
Oder soll ich mal Encrypt machen
Um zu checken, ob das dann
Auch, ja, wir machen mal Encrypt
ob das auch mit Snapshots funktioniert.
BTFS.
B-Cache-FS.
Nee, nee, nee.
Next.
Plasma.
Packages.
Printing-Support.
Und kann man hier auch schon
den Snapshot-Support irgendwie reinhauen?
Nee, ne?
Okay, Drucker testen wir auch noch.
Drucker und Snapshots.
Okay.
Dann machen wir das mal.
Install.
Zack.
Install now.
Geben.
Gucken, ob der jetzt auch schneller ist.
Aber das meiste war ja Package Download.
Arch, by the way.
Darf man eigentlich sagen, dass man Arch, by the way, used?
Wenn man Cache benutzt?
Bei Manjaro ist es ja fragwürdig.
Manjaro ist ja so ein Ding.
Da ist man eigentlich kein Arch-By-The-Way-User.
Ich hab nen Brother-Drucker, doch?
Hattest du schon Cosmic? Ne.
Aber mir hat das, was ich von KDE gesehen hab,
echt ganz gut gefallen.
Ich glaub, CacheOS ist ein...
CacheOS hat das Zeug
zur Mainstream-Distro,
finde ich.
Ich habe da immer so...
Also mich
täuscht da mein Gefühl selten so.
Es ist schwer, das
zu beschreiben, aber
das hat, glaube ich, genau die richtige
Kombination.
Es ist noch ein bisschen teilweise
unpoliert. Könnte noch
besser sein, aber die Basis ist da.
Was ist unpoliert?
Nee, es ist gar nicht unpoliert. Das hat noch ein paar
ein paar Ecken und Kanten,
aber ansonsten ist das
ziemlich gut, was ich jetzt gesehen habe.
Ja, ich finde, manche Sachen sind nicht ganz klar
Für die richtigen Noobs
Aber, das ist jetzt halt das Ding
Richtig krasse Noobs kommen eh nicht auf die Idee, Linux zu installieren.
So mein Vater zum Beispiel oder so.
Dem hab ich das installiert und der benutzt es halt einfach und da kann ich halt auch
die Settings machen.
Und jeder, der ein bisschen interessiert ist, der müsste eigentlich mit CacheUS klar kommen,
muss sich aber drauf einstellen, halt auch ein bisschen Geiz zu lesen.
So schätz ich das ein.
KDE ist viel zu umfangreich
kommt drauf an, was du willst
ja, also wenn du ein System willst, was du
richtig gut customizen kannst, ist KDE
doch top
ich mein
Noob
ist ja nicht gleich jemand, der nix mit seinem Rechner
machen will, der hat halt noch keine Ahnung
es gibt Noobs, die bleiben immer Noobs
und es gibt Noobs, die werden irgendwann mal advanced
es gibt durchaus leute sind jetzt noch nur was linux usage angeht aber haben ambitionen
und für die ist und gesund system glaube ich nicht verkehrt zumal es halt auch auf
art spaß ist das finde ich gut dass sie immer schön aktuelle packages schnellen package manager
wobei man ja wirklich ehrlicherweise sagen muss seit den letzten db an versionen ist abt richtig
schnell geworden ist auch mal aufgefallen wie es könnt ihr euch noch
daran erinnern wie abfahrt langsam abt immer war früher im vergleich zu pac man
mittlerweile flutscht das richtig das richtig gut geworden
was was was immer noch abfahrt langsam ist ist jam bzw dnf unter red hat ich
habe fedora schon eine ganze weile nicht mehr installiert ich habe keine ahnung
ob die neuen versionen besser sind die die man aktuell unter red hat die ist
schrott dies lahm ist fuck kenne ich von der arbeit
Ah, da stand was von Snapper, habt ihr das gesehen?
Lime irgendwas Snapper.
Wenn ihr das parallel noch auf Sway mit installieren könnt, ist das eigentlich eine gute Idee,
mehrere Desktops zu installieren, zum gucken, zu checken, ob es funktioniert.
Hat man ordentlich Desktops noch nachinstallieren oder ist das auch so ein Abfuck wie bei den
Printing Tools?
Ja und, was ist jetzt das Problem?
Hab ich doch.
Ist okay, dann machen wir jetzt doch Huefi.
Chat, ihr dürft es euch aussuchen.
Nehmen wir nochmal
Leim-Dingsbums oder
nehmen wir Krab?
Limeine oder Krab?
Limeine nochmal.
Ich weiß, was wir machen.
Wir machen jetzt mal einen Snapshot, wenn wir im Installer an der Stelle sind.
Sonst müssen wir den Scheiß immer wieder durchklicken und machen.
Achso Chat, und ihr könnt euch noch was überlegen.
Und zwar, ähm, 18 Uhr, wollte ich eigentlich was futtern.
Wir können, wenn ihr wollt, es auch so machen, dass ich das Essen hochhole und wir gucken
beim Essen das C++ Rant
Video weiter.
Wobei das vielleicht nicht gut für mich,
wenn ich beim Essen C++ Rant gucke.
Dann verschlucke ich mich.
Das gibt sofort Toastbrot.
Okay, also.
Leim-Mine.
Rittisch.
Englisch.
Next.
German.
No dead keys.
Next.
Erased disk.
BTRFS.
Encrypt system.
Hat Leimann vielleicht mit Encrypted System ein Problem?
Next.
Lass mal.
Man kann nur einen auswählen.
Ah, nee.
Hier kann man noch mehr auswählen.
Das machen wir jetzt aber nicht.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich kann mir jetzt nicht noch mehr Desktops angucken.
Ich installiere aber Sway trotzdem mal.
Nee, Hyperland.
Hyperland installieren wir.
Hyperland.
Hyperland und Sway installieren wir noch.
Weil ich wissen will,
ob das jetzt mit Wayland in der VM halbwegs funktioniert.
Wenigstens.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Okay.
Next.
printer printer support hammer printer support hammer hp printer scanner kam
den eigenen punkt ist auch lustig so lul we heißt das ding jetzt
next so und jetzt snapshot snapshot
Gut.
Snapshot.
Das ist auch so ein Bug seit den neuesten
VMware-Dingern. Du musst das Ding jetzt einmal
stoppen, dass der Snapshot schnell geht, sonst
dauert der Snapshot total lange.
Richtig, Monark S.
Vielleicht installiere ich auch wieder
meine alte VMware-Version. Die hat wenigstens nicht so
viel rumgebuckt.
Okay.
Install.
ja dann lassen wir jetzt mal machen wie lange läuft die installation so habt ihr
da ungefähr geguckt ich würde mal sagen so fünf minuten ungefähr da gehe ich mir
nämlich mal kurz unten essen klar machen während das installiert
Bin ich gleich wieder am Start.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das Achtos-Poll ist drin.
Das braucht auch ein bisschen länger, hä?
installing jetzt jetzt hat er gerade im boot oder es könnte auch sein dass das
so lange dauert weil vodafone heute wo da vorne und lahmes pack ist
Und wie lange hat es jetzt gedauert?
Fünf Minuten, oder?
Ich habe nicht drauf geguckt.
25 gestartet, dann brauchst du 5 Minuten, dann bist du fertig.
Hoffentlich kackt das jetzt nicht wieder ab.
Nee, hab ich doch nicht geguckt.
Kannst du irgendwelche Talks empfehlen?
Ich hab dieses Jahr eh sehr wenig Konferenztalks geguckt.
Da ist auch viel Schrott mittlerweile dabei.
Wo ich mir so denke, ey, den haben sie auch nur genommen, den Speaker, weil sie irgendwie das Programm füllen mussten und sowas.
Also ich meine das nicht explizit darauf bezogen, so generell bei Konferenzen war dieses Jahr wenig Interessantes dabei.
Weiß, dass man an den Terminal Outputs sieht, aber das ist auch nicht wirklich ergiebig, ja.
Die Defcon Videos haben auch richtig lang gebraucht dieses Jahr.
Neri, muss ich auch mal ausprobieren.
Ist das ein Tiling Window Manager?
Ich wollte Mango mal ausprobieren demnächst.
Das ist auch ein Wayland Tiling Window Manager.
Okay, das scheint aber zu funktionieren.
mit dem Installen, weil
sonst wäre er jetzt schon abgebrochen.
Okay, wir sind gleich fertig, Leute.
Es gibt ein Talk zum Deutschland-Ticket.
Okay, das könnte man sich mal angucken.
Running Shell Processors.
Dann run mal.
Placing the Fast.
Müsste alles rewritten in Rust sein,
dann wären wir schon fertig.
So wie unter Ubuntu,
wo die Hälfte dann nicht richtig funktioniert,
seitdem sie auf Rust Sachen umgestellt haben.
All done.
Restart now.
Jawohl, finish.
Moment.
Ach, dann muss ich, ups.
Ja, sechs Minuten hat es gebraucht.
ist der mutter ist viel hübscher
es ist das ist ein schönes schönes so fade in das gefällt mir
hyperlens plasma plasma und chat chat chat was ist m m managt
keine plastik was soll das sein
Lass mal gerade mal checken, ob Hyperland...
UWSM Managed, Hyperland.
Okay, ich habe schon mal zwei Mauszeiger.
Geht schon gut los.
schon mal zwei Mauszeiger am Start
ne, leg doch nicht irgendwie hier an meinem
ich kann auch
man kann doch nicht mal raus tappen aus der VM mehr
kann man
Ich würde gern meinen Linux neu starten.
Okay, so geht's.
Ich kann über einen anderen.
Also das ist nix.
Was ist denn?
Meta...
Super Q.
Passiert nix.
Passiert nichts.
Super M Exit Hyperland.
Okay, Exit Hyperland funktioniert.
Dann haben wir noch so Hyperland.
Aha.
Dann installieren wir mal Kitty.
Anscheinend wollen die standardmäßig Kitty haben.
UWSM.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt gleich...
Okay, warte mal. Wir starten mal Sway.
Mal gucken, ob das funzt.
Da gibt es immerhin ein Terminal.
Was ist das jetzt für ein Terminal?
Irgendjemand planen, was das für eins ist?
und ich habe englische tastatur
zu do it
jemanden planen wie man sway quittet wie drei ok
ich muss mal kurz nachgucken was
usm ist
usm
ja was ist der unterschied
universal wailand session manager ist einer empfohlen um halbweise auf system
die ist es das ist translation monka ist diese ganze karten die versuchen immer mitzudenken
faktisch so ab ok es ist auf jeden fall schon mal nicht verkehrt dass damit zu starten also
machen wir nochmal usm managed haben auch kitty installiert super q geht nicht geil
geil perfekt startet nicht dass das das ist so meine meine wayland wayland experience
die ich schon öfters hatte.
Der muss doch nicht checken, dass ich in der VM bin.
Kitty startet da nicht.
Plasma Wayland.
Ist von uns wenigstens.
Snapper Support haben wir doch schon.
Kann man hier Kitty starten?
Da startet es.
Ah nein, das Hyperland
packt es da immer rum.
Okay.
Dann können wir das jetzt ja eigentlich mal ausprobieren
mit den Snapshots.
Snap.
Lai mein Snapper-Restore.
Was ist das?
Ach, da kann man auswählen, mit was man booten will.
Moment, der macht Snapshots bei jedem Package-Install.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
In diesem Assistant müsste man das jetzt sehen.
Okay.
Ja gut, dann testen wir das doch mal aus.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt reboote, kann ich im Bootmanager auswählen, welchen Snapshot
ich gestorben will oder die tastatur backt wieder nur nur so ne die tastatur
backt wieder
Oh man, Alter, das ist ein VM-Bug.
Das kannst du ja keinem erzählen, Alter.
Wie kaputt kann man den Scheiß eigentlich gemacht haben?
Leute, wir haben ein Problem.
Wir können das Ding nicht bedienen, weil meine Tastatur
buggt und immer die letzte Tastatur
Druck nochmal wiederholt. Also ich versuche
es mal zu begleiten. Wenn ich jetzt Pfeil oben
nach unten drücke und wenn ich jetzt
Enter drücke, drückt er nochmal Pfeil nach oben.
Und dann macht er Enter direkt hinten dran.
Also komplett für den Arsch.
Wir können mal gucken, ob es Updates gibt.
Das ist halt verbuggter Shit.
War das so kaputt?
Okay, wir gehen jetzt einfach mal auf den hier zurück.
Äh, wie?
Ach so.
alter diese scheiß tastatur rumgepackt da reg ich mich jetzt auf man früher das
kannst du jetzt ein du kannst hier nichts auswählen drin weil brod kaum irgendeinen
Scheiß gemacht hat.
Rage Champ.
Richtig, Madge.
Aber was, das kann so wirklich nicht sein.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Okay, wie gehst du?
Das Problem ist,
da geht es auf Cache, pass auf, da geht es auf Cache
LTS
und man kann
ey, was eine Scheiße, die da
programmiert haben, ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Aber
das liegt nicht an CacheOS,
das meine ich nicht, ich meine Broadcom, die Scheiße
programmiert hat.
Okay, gehen wir einfach mal von aus, Leute.
Ohne Scheiß.
Snapshot-Restore funktioniert.
Okay?
Wir testen das nochmal auf echter Hardware dann.
Äh.
Irgendwie kann ich also nicht mal mehr booten
Oder was
Hack wait
Ich schau nur
Aber ich schau auch perspektivisch
Weil wer weiß wie lang
X noch irgendwie
gescheit funktioniert. Übrigens, rebooten
mit geht ja auch nicht richtig.
Was habe ich jetzt gebootet?
Meine Güte,
Alter, das ist ja grausam gerade.
Was ist eigentlich
aus dem Server geworden mit den VMs und dem
KVM? Was?
Jetzt bootet er, jetzt bootet er
LTS. Ich will nicht fucking LTS booten.
Ich will das normale booten. Egal,
booten wir LTS.
Was meinst du für einen Server mit
VMs und KVM?
Achso, du meinst das, wo ich da mit dem
Nvidia Streaming Zeug drauf zugreifen wollte?
Die Kiste
hab ich noch, da installieren wir CacheOS drauf
Ne, das hat nicht so gut funktioniert
Das hat rumgebackt
so plasma wir müssen noch mal was ausprobieren leute wir starten noch mal gucken ob das funst
das funzt hier laut keys d
laut keys ist bestimmt x was ich ausprobieren wollte ist ob firefox ordentlich funktioniert
und dann ob chrome funktioniert weil damit hatte ich öfters probleme unter wayland
Gucken wir mal, ob Kitty funktioniert.
Ne.
Kitty, Kitty, also
viele Programme crashen
unter
anderen Kompositoren als
KD.
Dann haben wir auch das Problem, dass Chrome nicht richtig funktioniert.
Guck, probier mal.
Sudo, Pac-Man, Minus S, Chrome, Chromium.
Deswegen ist eines der Gründe, warum ich nach KDE gucke.
Weil ich hab das Gefühl,
die Tage von X sind halt langsam
gezählt. Das wird nicht so sein,
dass es morgen nicht mehr geht,
aber immer mehr
Anwendungen werden in X-Support trocken
und es wird immer schlechter integriert sein
und vielleicht ist das wirklich
eine
gangbare Zukunft so.
Also KDE Plasma
in der VM.
Weil ich will es auf jeden Fall, solange ich noch Windows benutzen
muss,
will ich auf jeden Fall
Schei des Linux, was in der VM gut läuft.
Ja.
Okay, Chrome funktioniert hier auch mittlerweile.
Wobei das
letzte Mal immer gecrashed ist, nach kurzer Zeit
unter Wayland.
Was ist
kek w?
Ok, da war es Bescheid.
So, dann starten wir nochmal KD und jetzt machen wir mal die Druckereinrichtung.
I3 ist Gewöhnungssache, aber dann will man nichts anderes mehr.
Zumindest war es bei mir so.
So.
Also, dann machen wir mal Druckereinrichtung.
hier haben wir schon mal nichts mit printer
ich habe doch printer ach hier
printer settings konfigurierter settings also hier aber irgendjemand meinte doch in den kd
settings steht das auch mit drin also hier anscheinend nicht gibt es kein
print aber hier haben wir ad printer
aber der stets unter connected devices ja wahrscheinlich erst nachdem man das
hinzugefügt hatte
Hast du das Paket Print Manager von KDE?
Gucken wir mal.
Pacman-S Print Manager.
Ne, jetzt habe ich es aber.
Das ist jetzt...
Ah!
Das hätten sie auch mal mit installieren können.
Add.
ok jetzt schauen wir mal gibt sich sowas wie automatisch ich habe doch keine
ahnung was mein drucker hier macht pp lpd appsocket pp
hp jet direct
ich habe es im installer ausgewählt
pp pp ist anscheinend beste ok 12 16 81 punkt 224 hatte ich gesagt continue with address
hast du dein netzwerk auf matt ja aber warum wusste das problem warum nicht
Was habe ich denn für einen Drucker? Da muss ich mal selbst nachgucken hier.
brother mfc l 375 da habe ich mal habe ich mal danach gesucht ja mfc
brach wiederum also vor allem wer ist wirklich grausam gewonnen
mfc
gibt's nicht
ok mein drucker gibt es hier nicht was macht denn use pp everywhere
ok
pp everywhere was auch immer das ist
Hä? Wo ist der Drucker hin?
Ach, hier unten muss man auch auf Add drücken.
Idle. Okay.
Gibt's eine Print-Test-Page oder sowas?
Print-Test-Page.
Rating for PrintQ.
Okay. Mal gucken.
ich gehe mal gucken wir mal was waiting waiting for job to complete dann warten mama
macht er noch was der drucker ist normalerweise ziemlich schnell aber auch teuer
Soll ich mal rüber gehen gucken?
Wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz meine Pille nehmen hier.
Ich gehe mal kurz rüber, checken ob der was getrunken hat.
Ja.
Er hat gedruckt.
Die Anzeige ist einfach
pepega.
Die hat nicht aktualisiert,
die Anzeige. Meine Güte, ey.
Das sind so kleine Dinger. Die müssen doch nicht sein.
Hat ganz normal gedruckt.
War ein ziemlich verpixelter Pinguin drauf.
Und Text.
Aber das ist nicht verkehrt.
Man muss sagen, besser als unter Windows, wo man jetzt diese Kack-Brother-Software hier unten am Start hat, die rumätzt.
Was ist das hier?
KOS?
Achso, das ist Installer.
von CacheOS.
XOI didn't happen.
Dann hat es halt nicht gehappen.
Juckt mich nicht.
Ich mache euch jetzt kein Foto davon.
Das gefällt mir.
Also ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass in Zukunft zu benutzen
sollte der XO-Port immer schlechter
werden.
Und vielleicht schaffen wir es irgendwann mal, dass Anti-Cheat-Sachen auch auf Linux funktionieren.
Dann fliegt Windows runter.
Gewöhne ich mich an DaVinci Resolve für Video-Editing.
Dann scheiß auf Windows.
Ja, Gaben muss sich da mal drum kümmern.
Wir waren noch nie so nah dran wie 2026 jetzt, am Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Das stimmt. Das ist so.
Das heißt nicht, dass wir wirklich, dass es das Jahr des Linux-Desktops wird, aber wir waren noch nie so nah dran.
Also diese ganze Kernel-Level-Anti-Cheat-Geschichte, die ist mit Sicherheit so auf Windows angepasst,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die unter Linux funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht ob DaVinci Resolve Probleme hat mit manchen Distros, ich würde vermuten
das funzt einfach. Wollen wir mal checken ob das funktioniert.
Packages.
Das kann man nicht hier drüber installieren.
Da Vinci Resolve, oder?
Doch.
Mesa Git und Mesa A in Konflikt.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Aus welchen...
Welchen Quellen kommt denn Da Vinci?
Solve überhaupt.
Da muss ich das über die Shell machen.
Pac-Man?
Das ist bestimmt ein Our-Package.
ist es nicht ist es nicht okay
mesagit der ist der asf die providers available for opencl driver
was davon soll ich jetzt nehmen
OpenCL Mesa
So, gleich 18 Uhr, dann gucken wir wieder weiter den C++ Rant
Mein Toastbrot ist schon am Start
wenigstens haben sie die pacman konfiguration richtig gesetzt
was ist drauf quark und nutella also nicht alles auf einem das
wäre vielleicht ein bisschen abartig in kombination
KDE wird dann gerised
wenn ich es mal wirklich verwende
dann wird es gerised
Also das Wichtigste ist ja schon einmal, dass man richtige Wallpaper hat im Hintergrund.
weil wir gerade beim Thema
PepoFat sind.
Save Image As.
Wo wählt man denn die Wallpaper aus?
Add.
Jawoll!
Gleich die wichtigen Sachen im Hintergrund.
Ich habe es noch nie verwendet.
Fuck.
Okay, das geht in der VM nicht.
Das ist aber auch verständlich, dass sowas in der VM nicht gescheit läuft.
Aber insgesamt muss ich sagen, ganz ehrlich, es hat noch ein paar scharfe Kanten, ein bisschen unrund an manchen Stellen.
aber ich finde, CacheOS hat das Zeug zur Mainstream-Distro.
Gerade wenn die da weiter aktiv dran arbeiten, denke ich, da könnte was gehen.
Weil Linux-Noobs brauchen so einen Default-Choice, ja, so wie man lange Jahre gesagt hat, benutzt einfach Linux Mint.
aber jetzt im hinblick auf games und so was vielleicht ist das tatsächlich so dann in
zwei drei jahren vielleicht wirklich zu dieser default sache die man empfehlen kann neben cash
us kann ich mir vorstellen dass das klappt ich hab da ein ganz gutes gefühl bei kde gefällt mir
auch und das wichtigste bei kde ist also für mich ja schon fast schon fast ein grund kde zu benutzen
Es hat wobbly Windows.
Das ist der wichtigste Effekt seit Erfindung der Desktop-Effekte.
Ich wollte gar keine Videos als Hintergrund machen.
Das würde mich wahrscheinlich nur nerven.
Es ist kein Cursed-Effekt.
Das beste Effekt?
Wobbly Windows.
Und auch das hier, dass der Mauszeiger groß wird, wenn man wackelt, finde ich auch nice.
Wenn man einfach nur so macht, passiert nichts, oder?
Weil man so macht, an einer Stelle geht es direkt.
Basit, ne, Besit, Besite, wie soll man das aussprechen, das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das ist eine coole Sache.
So, dann lassen wir das mal für heute.
Ich futter jetzt hier was und wir gucken uns weiter.
Lass das mal an.
Wobei an nicht, ich mach es aus.
aber ich lasse es mal da vielleicht will ich dann zu kommen ein bisschen was basteln
wir gucken uns jetzt weiter das c++ rent video an ich wurde mein zussbrot dabei
ich glaube cash ist auch so ein bisschen richtung gaming distro aber
auch wohl ganz gut als die falls betriebssystem geeignet ohne jetzt auf krassen spielefokus
Hier, das sind wir.
Worst Programming Language of All Time.
14 Minuten haben wir schon geguckt und ich habe mich 45 Minuten lang aufgeregt.
Nicht über das Video, das Video ist gut.
Der erzählt einfach, was die Probleme, der spricht es mal an, was die Probleme bei C++ sind.
Und man sich fragen kann, was macht das C++ Standardgremium eigentlich schon seit dem Mittelalter?
Und kriegt nichts auf die Reihe.
So, let's go.
Jetzt, wir sind bei einem blieben Thema angekommen.
Header Files.
Also Header Files ist wirklich was ganz Grausames.
Dass es da nicht schon früher mal eine Lösung gab,
ist halt komplettes Unding,
weil jetzt, wo Module
mal irgendwie halbwegs theoretisch
möglich sind, das wird sich
das dauert 50 Jahre
bis sich das durchgesetzt hat
und wie gut Module und Headerfiles
zusammen harmonieren, weiß ich gar nicht
das ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke, alter
Headerfiles, ich kann es ja verstehen
dass in den 70er oder
wann auch immer C erfunden wurde
65 oder irgendwie, das ist ja uralt schon
warte mal
war in 70, ja doch,
ähm, dass man in den 70ern
das nicht besser, besser wusste,
konnte, nicht gebraucht hat,
kann ich ja noch verstehen, aber
Header-Files in 2025,
2026, Leute,
oder schon in 2020,
oder in 2015, warum?
Und du musst ja in C++
dann auch noch diese ganzen
Zeremonien machen mit
Pragma-Wands und so,
dass dein
Bundletool da oder dein
Preprocessor
nicht durchdreht.
Weil du mehrfach
included hast und so.
Das ist voll für'n Arsch.
Header-Files, wirklich der größte
Schrotz da.
Header-File. Then you need to make sure that they're
synchronized at all times.
Ich versuche,
ich versuche,
nur Header-Files zu erstellen
und meine Klassen so inline
da reinzuschreiben.
Manche Sachen gehen da aber nicht.
Weil ich finde dieses, du brauchst
zwei Files für eine Sache, ist es vom
Ansatz her schon komplett kacke.
Du schreibst gerade eine Bachelor-Arbeit
in C++.
Ja, GLHF.
... of the Don't-Repeat-Yourself-Principle.
eine eine
Die Aufnahme der Anwendung von Header-File ist exasperierend.
Es ist einfach zu vorstellen, wie das zu Bugs führen kann.
Nicht zu erwähnen, all die Redundanz der Anwendung, die da drin ist.
Wenn man eine Klasse schafft, die einen Konstrukteur benötigt, schreibt man die Klasse...
warum kann man nicht einfach alles was es gibt hier in dieser klasse drinne schreiben
90 prozent geht aber static variablen gehen zum beispiel nicht in jeder anderen normalen
programmier sprache der letzten 30 jahren oder so brauchst du nicht diese trennung
Aber in C++ pausen sie immer noch.
Das bedeutet auch, dass du zweimal die Menge Files checken kannst,
in Pull-Requests und Code-Reviews.
Es erzeugt einfach so viel...
Cobol! Oh je, oh je.
Wir haben auch mal Cobol gemacht.
An Weihnachten vor ein paar Jahren.
Das war grausam.
Aber immerhin, ich meine, Cobol merkst du halt an.
Cobol ist alt.
Okay.
Das Problem bei C++ ist,
das wird ja immer noch aktiv entwickelt und geupdatet,
aber es wird nicht besser gemacht.
es wird nur noch verwirrender und noch mehr Bullshit aneinandergeklebt.
JavaScript hat das vorgemacht.
JavaScript war auch grausam früher.
Es sind immer noch aus Rückwärtskompatibilitätsgründen viele grausame Sachen dabei,
aber das fällt dir heute so gar nicht mehr großartig auf.
JavaScript hat ja auch schöne Sachen übernommen.
Die haben einfach mal von C Sharp die Async-Away-Syntax geklaut.
Und die Lambda-Syntax übrigens auch.
Vollkommen in Ordnung. Gute Sachen.
Wir gucken nicht dasselbe, wir gucken weiter. Das Video geht zwei Stunden.
Ja, kenne ich voll recht.
Das ist halt auch so ein Ding, warum? Wir haben 2025.
Jede andere Programmiersprache der letzten 30 Jahre kriegt das hin, C++-Net.
You do this with header guards, which you have to put inside every single header file in your entire codebase.
Wo wir es gerade von hatten schon. Pragma-Once.
It's exhausting. And developers online argue incessantly about which technique to use.
Moment, Pragma-Once und Include-Guards ist was anderes? Gibt es da auch verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie man das macht?
Because there are at least two ways to do it. The first is with Include-Guards.
Was ist das denn?
If not defined header name, define
Achso, ah, okay, verstehe
Wenn es nicht definiert ist, dann wird es
defined und das nächste Mal nicht included
Warum sollte ich drei Zeilen schreiben, wenn ich
pragma once schreiben kann?
Wo ist da der Sinn von?
Also, was ich überhaupt brauche, ist ja schon für'n Arsch
Nicht? Nicht?
Okay.
Brauchst du vier Zeilen schon dafür.
Das ist echt
hirnrissig.
Ja, genau.
Der Compiler sollte nur einmal einen File inkludieren.
Und wenn du das nicht magst, sollte es eine Art und Weise sein, um zu optieren, und nicht die andere Art.
Entwickler versuchen manchmal, die Existenz von Header-Filen zu justizieren,
indem sie argumentieren, dass sie die öffentliche Interface deines Codes repräsentieren.
Aber die Klassen, die in Headern erklärt werden, haben ihre privaten Variablen und Funktionen auch da.
Das ist eine leckere Abstraktion.
Private Implementationsdetails gehören nicht in eine öffentliche Interface.
But since they exist there, you have to include those dependencies in the header file.
This means that anyone who includes your header file now by extension also ends up transitively including the files related to the implementation details of the class.
To add insult to injury, if you change a private member variable, you have to recompile everything that includes that header,
even if that change is purely internal and semantically irrelevant to client code.
Wisst ihr, was mich auch extrem... also ich hab mich ja gestern schon her drüber aufgelassen, was mich abfuckt.
Was mich aber richtig nervt in C++ ist, das liegt aber auch, das ist ein bisschen so in Richtung Header-Files und so, dass es keinen Package-Manager gibt. Ich weiß, es gibt ganz viele Third-Party-Package-Manager, aber das ist halt nicht das, also es gibt nicht sowas wie NPM mit einer offiziellen Registry oder Crates, Cargo-Gedöns.
Es ist so ein über 50 Jahre zusammengestückeltes Shit-Ding.
Das kriegst du nie wieder, da wird niemals eine gescheite Sprache draus werden.
Das heißt nicht wirklich Pimpel, oder?
Variablen wie diese sollten von der Anwendung her versteckt sein, ohne all diese unnötigen Arbeit.
C++ hat generell sehr seltsame Wege, Implementationsvorschläge zu verstecken.
Wenn du deinen Code von außen isolieren willst, kannst du einen anonymen Namespace nutzen,
oder du kannst deine Funktion statisch machen, wie wir vorhin besprochen haben, oder du kannst
beide gleichzeitig machen. Und wie ich schon gesagt habe, würde ich ein privates Keyword für diesen
Zweck lieber. Man könnte auch sehen, dass Leute versuchen, ihre Implementationsvorschläge
by putting them in a detail or implementation folder and corresponding namespace.
So advanced bin ich gar nicht in C++, das brauche ich für mein Microcontroller-Zeug nicht.
Ich bin eh der Einzige, der halt arbeitet.
But there's no built-in mechanism in C++ to prevent others from accessing the code in these folders.
Anyone can easily include these implementation files and use them anyway.
The user has to know which files are okay to include and which are not,
usually by reading documentation written by the creator of the library, which may or may not exist.
Ja, das stimmt.
In C++ ist alles
so im globalen
Namespace.
Was ich auch
richtig affig finde ist,
wo wir es gestern von hatten,
will ich hier wieder auf dem gleichen Beispiel
rumreiten, ja.
Aber warum ist alles in std?
Was soll das?
Warum ist das alles in std?
Warum muss fill n in std sein?
Ich hätte da einen Vorschlag.
Entweder
gebe es in dem Beispiel hier
entweder gebe es ein
v.fill
das geht natürlich nur, wenn du schon eine Instanz vom Vektor hast
v.fill, so keine Ahnung, vom ersten Index bis zum Ende
und da schreiben wir dann 69 rein, irgendwie sowas
das wäre eine Möglichkeit, gibt es nicht
das nächste wäre, was man machen könnte
standard Vektor fill
so eine statische, globale
aber halt passend dazu dass man das irgendwie zusammen bringt und wenn das
für alles machen willst dann wenigstens wenigstens irgendwie standard container
film oder sowas aber warum muss es allen ernstes standard film alles ist
irgendwie ein std drin
verstehe ich nicht und dieser syntax hier reden wir erst mal gar nicht da
hatten wir gestern schon davon die inklud präprozessor direktiv ist
Das ist nur eine glorifizierte Kopie- und Paste-Operation.
Es verwendet alle Typen, Funktionen und andere Symbols
aus dem Header-File direkt in deinen Code,
was in der Tat deine Autocomplete-Suggestionen
mit Funktionen und Typen aus all eurer Code-Base verursacht.
Verstehe die Situation, in der du einen Header inkludierst,
der 10 weitere Header inkludiert,
und jeder dieser Header inkludiert 10 weitere Header,
und so weiter und so fort.
Du erhältst ein Millionen Symbols aus dem gesamten Dependency-Tree,
die deine Autocomplete flutten und es nicht nützlich machen.
Ich kann mich nicht darauf verlassen, Tab zu nutzen,
um meinen Code zu Autocomplete zu machen,
because it's replete with irrelevant suggestions.
This is why developers hate it when noobs include Windows.h.
It imports like another million symbols into your project.
And macros make everything even worse.
Macros in C++ are basically search and replace commands
that happen before your code is actually compiled.
If you're right to define size 100,
you're telling the compiler to replace every instance of size with 100.
Macros don't respect the type system or scoping rules
and they have no semantic awareness
and they operate indiscriminately across all code
which is downstream in the include chain.
Das bedeutet, dass wenn du einen Header mit Makros inkludierst, diese Makros deinen Code überwinden können, weil diese Such- und Verwenden-Kommande jetzt aktiv in deinem Code sind, ob du es möchtest oder nicht.
manchmal musst du es auch als erstes inkluden damit die anderen mit das mitkriegen das ist
super wieder nicht verstehbarer schritt nots ist leckern weiten sommer in der haus in der
sicherlich starb rearranging furniture without telling you imagine that you have functions and
message and then you include windows.de windows.de has a macro für send message which ends up
overriding your send message function or imagine if somebody writes a macro to make private public
Ich meine, er lernt schon, dass sowas geht, ne?
Guck mal, der regt sich ja auch drüber auf, dass alles in SCD ist.
Du kannst, also in der normalen Sprache kannst du sowas auch ordentlich
includen, dass du sagst
ähm
äh, was soll ich, use
bla bla bla
oder import from
oder irgendwie sowas
und dann musst du kein
Namespace mehr davor schreiben.
Das geht glaube ich teilweise
in C++ auch, aber da gibt es dann auch wieder Probleme
mit diesem using statement.
Ja.
Also Java zeigt das übrigens auch, ja.
Die haben die letzten zwei Sprachversionen
richtig gute Features eingebaut.
Und das sage ich als Java-Noob, ja.
Also ich war ganz überrascht davon, dass sie so eine Art Link haben, dass diese Streaming-API, dass Record-Types und solche Geschichten.
Also man sieht, das geht, wenn man will.
Aber C++-Cremio macht lieber weiterhin Shit.
Amen.
Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu Qu
Beispiel, the authentication system silently switches to using an insecure hash, which
was made for testing purposes. The implication here is that you shouldn't use deeply nested
namespaces.
Du kannst diese Sprache nicht verstehen. Das ist unmöglich. Du kannst nur was verstehen,
was einer gewissen Logik folgt. Auch wenn du die Logik vielleicht noch nicht verstanden
hast. Ja, aber irgendwann wirst du sie verstehen. Aber da ist keine Logik dahinter.
C++-Projekte
wenn in der Realität sie nur ein fragiles Werkzeug für die grundlegenden Design-Frauen von Headerfilen sind, die sie von C erhielt haben.
Namespaces sind ein schreckliches Patch, das einen unnötigen syntaktischen Bedarf und Fußgänger verursacht,
den man nicht erkennt, bis man zehn Jahre vor dem Entwicklung seines Code-Bases ist.
Nicht zu erwähnen, dass Makros nicht sogar Namespace-Boundare respektieren,
also haben Sie immer noch das Problem, um sich darüber zu kümmern.
Es ist verrückt, wie viel Schmerz und Schmerzen Headerfile verursachen,
einfach weil die Kreatoren von C nicht die Wissenswerte hatten,
um zu prädikten, dass C in großen-scale Code-Basen benutzt wird.
Das ist mal ein gutes AI-Bild.
das trifft wirklich
das ist wirklich
ein gutes
Abstraktion
der Realität
es gibt auch
gute AI Bilder anscheinend
wobei ich C
und C++ gar nicht in einem
ich mag das nicht, wenn man das so in einem
Atemzug nennt
warum ist es zweimal C Sharp?
weil AI Kunst
ist
weil C ist an sich
eine gute Programmiersprache.
Minimalistische, low-level,
ziemlich alte,
aber an sich in sich
irgendwie noch halbwegs konsistente
Programmiersprache, ganz im Gegensatz zu C++.
Ungewöhnlich, ich sehe nie jemanden, der diesen Trick reden will, für irgendeinen Grund.
Vielleicht werde ich ihn im nächsten Video beenden.
Also, macht sicher, dass ihr euch interessiert.
zum Video rein.
Compile Times.
Oh ja.
Also größere Codebases
zu kompilieren, das dauert ewig.
So if you include String in your codebase in a thousand different CPP files,
the compiler will stupidly compile String a thousand times.
Weiß das Ding fickler?
And keep in mind that the String-Header also includes a bunch of other stuff,
which includes a bunch of other stuff.
And all that needs to get compiled again and again.
This is an outrageous waste of CPU-Cycles, energy and time.
There is a hack to fix this, it's called a pre-compiled header.
This is a special header file, which you can put all your most used includes
to have them compiled only once.
So now all you have to do is include the precompiled header and you're good to go.
But honestly, precompiled headers feel like a hack.
In fact, the entire language feels like a broken mess with a thousand hacks littered everywhere to get anything to work reasonably well.
Precompiled headers can be perplexing for beginners.
In the past, Visual Studio used to automatically create a PCH file for you when you created a new project.
But it confused beginners so much that they now omit it in your versions.
These days it's an opt-in feature.
There's actually so much theory about how to speed up compilation.
Es wird nur immer schlimmer.
Ich meine, für eine gute Sache, die sie einbauen,
bauen sie zehn Crap-Sachen ein.
Ja.
Das hat doch bestimmt auch irgendwelche Bugs.
Es gibt ja auch Sachen, die waren mal modern C++, sind aber mittlerweile wieder outdated, so Autopointer und sowas.
but not what it means.
You'll be taught that it holds a memory address,
but there's not a whisper about ownership semantics.
Raw pointers convey something very important.
They convey that they are non-owning.
This has certain implications,
like how you're not responsible for its life cycle.
And if it's stored in a member variable,
depending on the context,
you might need to make sure that the enclosing object
does not outlive the object that the pointer is pointing to.
zur Compile-Zeit,
weil du gucken musst, dass der Borrow-Checker und alles drumherum
glücklich ist.
Aber dann hast du keine Probleme mehr.
Wo warst du so lange?
Wieso? Ich bin noch da. Ich war auch die letzten
Tage da und die letzten Monate.
Ich war nur auf YouTube nicht am Start.
Auf YouTube,
ich hab ein paar Probleme gehabt,
das letzte Jahr über.
Aber ich war vorgestern
ganz kurz davor, ein Video aufzunehmen
zu Silvester.
Aber dann
konnte ich mich doch nicht überwinden.
Die Rust-Syntax ist teilweise auch echt
grausam. Wobei die anderweitig
grausam ist als C++.
Die Rust-Syntax ist halt notwendig,
dass du dieses ganze
Compile-Time-Check-Gedöns machen kannst,
was Rust macht.
Dafür ist die Syntax schon okay,
aber die ist halt saumäßig komplex.
die ist aber wenigstens
irgendwie noch logisch
wenn auch super kompliziert
jetzt stellt euch mal vor
Rust wäre vom C++ Standardgremium
standardisiert
und weiterentwickelt worden
wie das dann aussehen würde
ja schön dass du da bist
geil
Light Tracer.
Was?
Das hat er sehr schön philosophisch verpackt.
Praktiken und Prinzipien und oft Key-Konzepte und Ideen auslösen. Die
populärsten YouTube-Videos sind nur der Blinde, den Blinden zu führen. Ich habe ein Video gesehen, das
letztes Jahr viral wurde, das 15 Jahre C++-Wissenschaften, Tipps für neue Programmierende,
genannt wurde. Dieser Typ gibt die typischen Feel-Good-Bro-Minds, die im Grunde genommen
zu sagen sind, dass du nur selbst bist, Bro, und nur patient bist, Bro, und es gibt keine solche Sache
als eine schlechte Linie von Kode, also nimm es einfach ein Stück nach dem anderen und alles wird in Ordnung.
hab ich's auch nicht kapiert.
Ich glaube, was er sagen wollte, ist,
dass, ähm,
bei Raw Pointers eben nicht
der Pointer dafür zuständig ist,
das Memory wieder zu freeen, sondern
ja,
ich nenn's mal so, das andere, was ihn auch
erstellt hat.
Ich glaube, sowas wollte er, darauf wollte er irgendwie raus.
Ja, bei dem Unique Pointer
sieht das ja anders aus. Unique Pointer
destructet ja auch, wenn er
out of scope geht.
Ich glaube, so was in der Richtung wollte er sagen.
Na geil.
Ich habe so eine hohe Meinung an der Sprache.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich ein Blog oder ein Video sehe,
wie C++ ein Blaster ist,
oder dass jemand die Sprache liebt...
Alle anderen, die C++ gut finden,
Kack-Noobs.
Da bin ich auch dafür.
Lass mich mal kurz
den Reddit-Post lesen.
Hello, I'm a software engineer
with a software for 12 years.
My most fluent language is C-Sharp.
Das ist eine gute Sprache.
But I'm just as dangerous
in JavaScript, TypeScript, Sprinter...
So, okay, jetzt hat er was in...
Also im Prinzip ist das eigentlich das untere Interessante.
Wow!
This language is how I think.
Ach du Scheiße.
Was ist mit dem seinem Gehirn los?
Dentke.
Haben wir Dentke als Emote?
Dentke brauchen wir.
Dent...
Dentke.
Wir haben nicht Dentke als Emote.
Sekunde, das muss ich hinzufügen.
Dentke.
Das ist das passendste Emote dafür, was es gibt.
Add to Oblons.
So, Chat.
Dentke wurde hinzugefügt.
Das ist genau das, wie ich mir den Typ, der diesen Reddit-Post gemacht hat, vorstelle.
Richtig Dentke.
Ja, hier oben ist ein, hier unten ist ein, ein, ein, ein, ein Dentke am Start mit.
FFZ, richtig, bei Fatshit mittlerweile.
Was hat er denn sonst noch geschrieben hier?
Das ist, wie ich denke, die ultimative Freiheit.
Ich lerne immer noch, aber ich habe mich in meinen Computer geklärt,
die letzten zwei Wochen, als ich diese Sprache lerne und bilde.
Ich habe eine sehr einfache Erklärung, um C++ zu machen.
Und ich will es unerklärlich klar machen.
Wenn du C++ magst, dann weißt du es nicht.
Genau, das ist das, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Heißt im Endeffekt, alle Noobs,
es sind alle Noobs, die es gut finden
und die richtigen Pros finden es kacke.
Was im Endeffekt heißt,
ich muss der übelste C++-Pro sein,
so krass wie ich das immer
und häufig ist das,
ich das immer gerne hate.
Advanced C++-Programmer confirmed.
Wie? Nicht Standard Back Inserter?
Warum gibt es überhaupt Pushback und Emplaceback?
Aber das ist langsam, es flüssigt den Buffer.
Du solltest den neuen Charakter benutzen, oder besser gesagt, den Standard-Print-Line.
Die Liste geht einfach weiter und weiter.
Die Sprache hat sich so viel verändert und bleibt immer weiterentwickeln,
dass es schwer ist, wirklich zu wissen, was modernes C++ überhaupt ist.
Willst du modernes C++ lernen, oder moderner C++, oder modernerist C++,
oder postmodern C++?
Was reden wir hier überhaupt?
Ja, das ist der richtige Zeitpunkt, an dem die Industrie bewegt wird.
What the fuck ist das für eine Sonntagswitter?
Alter, das sieht ja schlimmer aus als vollgekleistertes Rust.
...
in der notation included a forward slash in a correct symbol and some more keywords it looks
like a nightmare to read and maintain in there's even more syntax and symbols proposed for the
upcoming contracts and reflection for guys at the rate we're going c++ 30 ist probleme der
look like this the other problem to be mindful of is that people often confuse c++ was sie
Naja, was ich meine mit Folgekleister am Rust, wir brauchen mal gucken, ob wir uns Chat-GPT oder sowas...
Warte mal, ne, warte mal. Rust, where, example, trades, lifetime.
Ich habe da doch letztens ein Video zu gesehen.
Trades Feature.
Rust.
Was ist das?
Das ist es.
Irgendwas mit Rust complicated feature explained war das wieder.
Rust most complicated feature explained.
Genau. Da sagt mir jetzt mal einer, dass das schön zu lesen ist, Leute.
Können wir nicht sagen, dass das hübsch ist?
Gut, besser als C++ ist keine Messlatte, Leute.
Es ist so gut wie alles besser als C++.
Aber schön zu lesen ist das jetzt wirklich nett.
Aber es hat wenigstens eine, es hat wenigstens eine, also man kann das verstehen irgendwie noch, ja.
Es hat irgendwie eine gewisse Logik, der das folgt, nicht so wie bei C++.
Ich kann jetzt nicht, also ich könnte jetzt nicht hundertprozentig euch direkt erklären, was das macht.
Also es ist irgendwie, das sind Lifetime Annotations, das hier oben sind Lifetime Annotations, dass der Compiler weiß, Argumente, die du übergibst, also die Lifetime Annotations sind dafür da, dass der Compiler checken kann, dass das, was du returnst von der Funktion, nicht quasi, nee umgedreht, umgedreht.
dass das
nicht länger leben kann
als die Parameter, die du reinsteckst
so rum
also wenn du jetzt einen String da reinsteckst
der nach der Funktion wieder
out of scope geht und das dann
nicht damit übereinstimmt, wie du den
Return-Wert verwendest, dann knallt es
du sagst dem, okay, das kann nicht länger
leben als die Lifetime
von den zwei Parametern, die du übergibst
das ist halt auch ein bisschen eklig, aber man kommt
irgendwie dahinter, so, übergeben wird
das Ganze hier als Referenz.
Lifetime-Parameter brauchst du prinzipiell
nur bei Referenzen,
weil wenn du was movest,
dann ist es ja, dann outet das das hier
ja, dann ist es ja keine, brauchst kein
Lifetime-Annotation.
Das hier ist irgendwie
für Memory, frag mich nicht.
Dünn ist
eine Geschichte, sowas wie Interface,
sowas wie Interface in C-Sharp ist das.
Dass du sagst, du
except, du returnst
einen Typ, der
Future implementet,
Future is a trade, also quasi
eine Art Interface
und
also dieser Typ muss
Future implementieren,
Send implementieren,
genau,
muss Future und Send implementieren.
Das ist quasi ein Interface.
Also es ist schon,
also schön zu lesen ist es nicht,
ja, ganz ehrlich.
Aber wenn mich jetzt einer fragt, so ein super komplexes C++ Template zu lesen versus das hier, ganz ehrlich, ich brauch bei beidem eine ganze Weile, bis ich es gecheckt habe, aber das hier würde ich wahrscheinlich schneller checken.
Und vor allem in der Zukunft, wenn ich so Sachen öfters lese, wahrscheinlich auch immer schneller.
Aber ich will nicht sagen, dass das schön ist.
Also das sieht auch abadig aus.
Aber in Rust ist es halt notwendig, dass Rust seine Compile-Time-Checks machen kann.
Das geht quasi nicht anders.
sonst wäre Rust nicht Rust
ohne die Features
so, gucken wir mal weiter
wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben überhaupt
Chat
wem fällt ein Feature ein, was C kann und C++ nicht
Mir fällt spontan nur eins ein
Any five headers im Chat?
Denen was einfällt?
Ist auch schwierig
Ne ich meine was was
Ich meine ein Feature
Das C kann aber C++ nicht
Struct, ja, das geht in die richtige Richtung
Struct, du kannst in C++
nicht diese Standard
diese Struct Initialization
verwenden, gescheit
wie es in
wie es in C ist
in C kannst du Structs irgendwie so
irgendwie so
initialisieren, ja.
So, und das geht in C++
nur so zu 90%.
In C++ musst du darauf achten, dass du das
in der richtigen Reihenfolge definierst.
Und in C ist das egal.
Ähm,
Nee, hab ich nicht mitgekriegt, dass Espressif da viel in Rust investiert.
Wäre cool, wenn es noch eine Alternative zu C++ gäbe.
Für Microcontroller.
Wäre natürlich schwierig, weil ganz viele Libraries halt nur in C verfügbar sind.
Aber Niri, hab ich mir sogar schon aufgeschrieben, glaube ich.
Hier in Streamthemen.
Niri, guck.
Romango wollte ich auch ausprobieren.
Plus, as if the two aren't completely different languages.
Furthermore, a common question I see on internet forums is about whether you should learn C before learning C++,
as if it's a prerequisite or something.
But the answer is a resounding no.
Idiomatic C looks very, very different from idiomatic C++.
That's true.
They're different languages.
And one of the first things that the C++ community tries to hammer down into beginners' minds
is that you shouldn't write C++ like C.
Don't use C-style strings, use standard string.
Don't use C-Style Arrays, use Standard Array or Standard Vector.
Don't use Enum.
Ja, das Ding ist, wenn du aber Interop machen musst mit C-Sachen,
dann kommst du an manchen Sachen nicht vorbei.
Use Enum Class.
Don't use Union, use Standard Variant.
There's a whole list of things that you need to remember on what not to do.
But the key takeaway is, don't ever, ever, ever write C++ like it's C.
Unless you're writing C-Style C++ and it's okay.
You see, some people really like the simplicity of C
und sie hassen die Komplexität und Feature-Bloat von C++.
Wie steht das?
Sie schreiben also ein Style von C++, das C ist,
mit nur ein paar C++-Fähigkeiten.
Das heißt C-Style C++.
Und das ist das Problem mit C++.
Jedes Ding, das du lernst,
hat einen überraschenden Endfall,
der super wichtig ist.
Du wirst nie C++ wie C schreiben,
außer wenn du ein C-Style C++-Codebase arbeitest.
Dann musst du das.
Du wirst Stattikast verwenden,
wenn du das kannst,
aber dann wirst du lernen,
dass du das nicht für Enums tun sollst.
Standard to underlying. Alter, warum ist alles in std drin?
Um mal wieder auf das Thema zu kommen.
Standard to underlying instead.
You're taught that returning a pointer to a local variable is dangerous.
Ja, hätte ich jetzt auch gedacht, dass das keine gute Idee ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Because the memory is deallocated when the function returns.
But then it turns out that this doesn't apply to string literals,
because they have static storage duration and exist...
Ja, okay, okay.
Ja.
Ja, okay, kann ich nachvollziehen.
Nett, nett, sommer nicht.
Ach ja.
Ist ja eigentlich gedacht.
Tja, das Problem hast du in Rust nicht.
da kommst du nicht drum herum, dann wird es einfach gemovt.
Du musst es nicht explizit schreiben.
So, kurz gucken.
ESP
ist
Libraries creates examples for using Rust on expressive.
so
sogar mbt ls haben die schon am start
uhr
das ist ja sehr nice
vielleicht sollten wir noch mal rast auf dem sp probieren
hier würde das jubiläum statt die tat jules kanzler references everywhere for
performance reasons but then you learn that it's actually faster to copy small
objekt in der passen bei reference so ex-leute pass bei konstra franz ist die objekt ist mal
also ehrlich gesagt ich finde die c style cast syntax um ein vielfaches angenehmer ich weiß
Eis, das ist nicht so safe, ja, oder hast du manche Checks nicht, aber ich finde es einfach deutlich angenehmer, sowas hier zu schreiben, anstelle, was weiß ich, Static, Casts, Ints, blub, so.
Ey, hör mal auf, L-Value, R-Value, Alter, mal kannst du so schreiben, da ist eine Referenz, manchmal schreibst du so, es ist wieder was anderes, checkt in C++ auch keine Sau.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, die ist ja nur irgendwie 5000 Seiten lang.
Aber es sind nur 1841 Pages.
Es ist fast 2000 Seiten lang.
Und wenn du Fragen hast, dann besuche die Cpp-Referenz.
Da haben wir uns auch schon öfters drüber lustig gemacht, über diese Seite.
Wie die aufgebaut ist und ausschaut, ey.
Wir hatten sie ja eben wieder auf.
Na gut, in dem Beispiel ist es jetzt hier nicht so, aber...
Wenn ich sowas hier schon sehe, Alter...
Oh ne, oh ne, Build Systems. Nicht vorhandene Build Systems, die zur Sprache gehören. Also die mit maintained und mit dabei sind, so alles aus einer Hand. Gibt's ja nicht. Gibt keinen Package Manager, gibt kein Build System.
standard abr also das ist tatsächlich hier kein bild kein bildsystem und kein
standard package manager das ist halt das
das sind so dinge wo ich mir denke da anstatt die 580 bescheuerten anderen
sachen einzubauen das sind so dinge da hätte man da hätte
man 15 jahr für gebraucht aber da hätte man es jetzt
... Standard Package Manager und kein Standard ABI.
Das Ergebnis ist ein tiefenfragmentiertes Ökosystem, wo jedes Stück von default unabhängig ist,
jedes Setup ist eine bespannende Rube-Goldberg-Maschine
und sogar die einfachste Aufgabe braucht eine ausreichende Menge von Boilerplate,
Konfiguration und tribaler Wissen.
Lass uns die Kompilierungen zuerst diskutieren.
Laut Wikipedia gibt es 31 Kompilierungen für C++,
aber die Haupt 3 sind Microsoft Visual C++, der default auf Windows ist,
GCC, der default auf Linux ist
und Clang, die die Anwendung auf MacOS ist.
Jeder Compiler hat verschiedene Pro's und Con's in Bezug auf seine Optimierungskapazitäten,
Features, Tools und Extensions.
Compiler-Extensions sind nicht-standard-Features, die von Compiler-Vendoren geändert werden,
um zusätzliche Funktionalität zu bieten, die das C++-Standard spezifiziert.
Diese Extensions können...
Ja, das Ding ist, die unterstützen ja zum größten Teil noch nicht mal das, was da Standard spezifiziert.
...Debugging oder plattformspezifische Kapazitäten.
Einige Beispiele davon wären Pragmas, bauten Funktionen und Intrinsiken, Attribute, Inline-Aassemblung und custom Keywords und Modifier.
Aber weil es einzigartig für jeden Compiler ist, ist es oft empfohlen, sie nicht zu nutzen.
Oder sie zu nutzen, weil sie die Portabilität reduzieren.
Und das ist, warum man manchmal sieht, dass IF-Define so aussehen, wie das, auf Kodebasis.
Es ist ein Weg, um Compiler-Extensionen zu nutzen, während man so viel Portabilität wie möglich behält.
Compilers haben auch eine andere Zeit, in der sie neue C++-Fähigkeiten implementieren.
In den letzten Jahren hat MSVC die Führung gemacht, die neuesten C++-Fähigkeiten zu implementieren,
mit den anderen hinterhergelassen durch eine signifikante Margin.
Aber es sieht so aus, als hätten sich die Dinge im letzten Jahr abrupt verändert,
weil Microsofts Prioritäten geändert haben, wahrscheinlich um AI zu konzentrieren oder so etwas.
Und einer ihrer größten C++-Experten ist letztendlich für Citadel geblieben.
Um die gleiche Zeit hat MSVC wirklich seine Momentum verloren.
Das heißt, eines der größten Probleme mit MSVC ist,
dass es einen sehr schlechten SIM-Decoder generiert, im Vergleich zu anderen Compilern.
Okay, dazu kann ich nichts sagen.
Absolut kein Plan von.
So, das ist ein gutes Schlusswort.
Einfach direkt Assembler programmieren anstatt C++.
Chat. Wir gucken das nächste Mal weiter.
so zum Stream ausklingen lassen,
ist das ein super Video.
Nächstes Mal machen wir wahrscheinlich mit Z-Server weiter.
Schauen wir mal.
Machen wir mal eine VM aus.
Kurz hier updaten.
Guck mal hier.
Bam.
Package Updates.
Ich habe keinen Anwendungsfall aktuell dafür.
Für Zigbee-Geschichten.
NixOS, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich habe es mir ein bisschen am Rande immer angeguckt,
mit dem NixOS Package Manager.
Aber ich habe so überhaupt keinen Anwendungszweck
für richtig für NixOS.
Ja, Nix installieren als erweiterter Package Manager
für manche Sachen, das ist ja noch das eine.
Aber NixOS und diese komische Nix Language Config,
das ist mir zu pfeifert.
Und ich, also zu pfeifert ohne wirklichen Mehrwert für mich.
Der Sensor im Teich funktioniert doch nicht.
Das liegt aber nicht am Sensor,
sondern dass ich mit meinem ZigBee Stick rumgefrickelt habe.
Für Server, ich glaube nie, dass ich nix zuerst mal im Business Enterprise Umfeld
auf Servern sehen werde, solange es da nichts gibt mit Herstellersupport.
Wie oft muss man den PC neu auf?
Also gar nicht.
Oder was meinst du?
Ich habe seit Jahren
einmal Windows jetzt installiert,
weil ich Secure Boot aktivieren wollte
und Battlefield 6 zu spielen.
Achso, den Grund für NixOS.
Ganz ehrlich,
bei NixOS,
ich erkenne, dass das eine coole Technologie ist,
auch für reproduzierbare
Builds, wobei ich da nicht weiß, warum man es braucht,
wenn es Docker-Stells gibt.
Wobei,
bei Docker hast du ja immer noch ein bisschen das Problem,
da ist ja nicht alles exakt gepinnt.
Wenn du da reinschreibst,
Debian Trixi, dann ist es die immer zum
Tag, wo du das Image baust, aktuelle
Debian Trixi-Version.
Aber es ist immer so, es ist
reproduzierbar genug.
Ich verstehe auch nicht wirklich
den Benefit,
den ich von XOS hab.
Deswegen hält sich meine
Motivation da, was zu lernen, auch in Grenzen.
Aber, Leute, ich geh jetzt auf.
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Und wir sehen uns. Bis dann, macht's gut.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart. Wem's gefallen hat,
kann jetzt hier einmal auf
Follow drücken. Freu ich mich, wenn ihr das nächste Mal
auch wieder mit dabei seid.
Außerdem ist grüne Pfeile beim Follow-Counter eh immer beste.
Und wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.
Weiß ich noch nicht genau, ob aufwachen, streamen oder später.
Weiß ich noch nicht.
Bis dann. See you.